programming throwdown episode 81 mailbag take it away jason hey everybody so uh yeah i had an interesting time sending out the Christmas gifts. Patrick and I, you know, took a morning. We kind of packaged them all up. We signed them all. We saw a lot of people have gotten them. So we've gotten some some people have tweeted, you know, pictures of their of their logo. That's totally awesome. Definitely keep doing that. I've been resharing all of the ones that, that, uh, that I see. Um, so that's pretty exciting. Um, yeah, I went to the, to the post office, which has tons of these and, uh, the ones that were domestic, you know, just put a stamp on, put them in the slot. And then I took the international ones to this gentleman and, uh, he told me it would cost $14, uh. I have to fill out a customs form.
Programming Throwdown 第81期，邮件袋环节，Jason，开始吧。大家好，嗯，是的，我寄送圣诞礼物时经历了一段有趣的时光。Patrick和我花了一个上午，把它们都打包好，并签了名。我们看到很多人已经收到了。有些人发推特晒出了他们的Logo，这太棒了。一定要继续这样做。我一直在转发我看到的那些，这真的很令人兴奋。嗯，我去了一趟邮局，那里有很多这种包裹。国内的包裹，我贴上邮票投进投递口就行了。然后我把国际包裹交给了一位先生，他告诉我需要14美元，我还得填写一份海关申报单。
I'm not sure. We're still trying to figure out what to do internationally. I have a couple of ideas. I definitely want to do something, but it might end up being something digital, so I apologize for that. For everyone domestic, we did get those out. If you didn't get it and you're in the
我不确定。我们还在想办法处理国际邮寄的问题。我有几个想法。我肯定想做点什么，但最终可能只能是数字化的东西，对此我深表歉意。对于国内的每一位听众，我们确实已经寄出了。如果你在
US, let us know. And yeah, it was pretty exciting. It was pretty fun. It was something that Patrick and I both realized that things like running your own Kickstarter and stuff like that are actually really hard. Once you have to do things that at scale it's really difficult maybe we could consider if anyone's interested and you i think we have many in different places but there are a number in europe maybe we could mail one package to europe and that person could remail them to other people yeah that's true or uh maybe if there's someone out there in europe with a laser cutter oh maybe they could do it and then we could try to like reimburse them. Yeah. Yeah. So if you have a laser cutter and you're in Europe and you're willing to do some
美国但还没收到，请告诉我们。这真的很令人兴奋，也很有趣。Patrick和我意识到，像运营自己的Kickstarter众筹项目之类的事情其实非常困难。一旦你需要进行规模化操作，难度就很大。也许我们可以考虑一下，如果有人感兴趣的话——我想我们在不同地方有很多听众，但在欧洲也有不少人——也许我们可以寄一个大包裹到欧洲，然后由那个人再分发给其他人。是的，确实如此。或者，如果欧洲那边有人有激光切割机，也许他们可以制作，然后我们尝试报销他们的费用。是的。所以，如果你在欧洲有激光切割机，并且愿意做一些
extra work on the side, let us know, send us an email or hit us up on discord. Are they more than the $14? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's, that's your upper bar, right? I mean, it has to be cheaper than that. Cool. Well, we're doing a mailbag episode so we've trimmed down the the intro stuff but i wanted to cover one thing i saw that was pretty interesting uh there was a article a series of articles actually that we have a link in the show notes about disney had released one of their internal scene descriptions for one of the island scenes from the movie Moana in an open source format this I believe it's PBRT physical physically based rendering technology or I don't remember what the T is for but basically they took their internal data format which I guess is some
额外的副业，请告诉我们，给我们发邮件或在Discord上联系我们。它们超过14美元了吗？是的。那是你的上限，对吧？我的意思是，必须比那个便宜。酷。好吧，我们正在做邮件袋环节，所以我们精简了开场内容，但我还是想讲一件我看到的非常有趣的事。有一篇文章，实际上是一系列文章，我们在节目备注里有链接，讲的是迪士尼以开源格式发布了电影《海洋奇缘》中一个岛屿场景的内部场景描述。我相信这是PBRT，基于物理的渲染技术，我不记得T代表什么了，但基本上他们采用了他们的内部数据格式，我想这大概是某种
proprietary WDAS Walt Disney Animation Studios and they uh converted the entire sort of scene to this open source description and so it's a picture of you know the island and some palm trees and it's a 3d description of all this and the textures that overlay all of this for sort of i don't exactly understand how all of it works but for sort of one point of view uh and you get some of the ocean stuff you get some of the mountains and i guess it's supposed to be enough of a description that if you do rendering uh and the magic that goes behind that which we'll leave out for sake of time that you can reproduce what it would have looked like in the movie um and i i this apparently came as a result of a panel discussion where some people asked like why are you sort of still using proprietary stuff like
专有的WDAS（华特迪士尼动画工作室）格式，他们把整个场景转换成了这种开源描述。所以这是一张岛屿和一些棕榈树的照片，这是所有这些东西的3D描述，以及覆盖在上面的纹理。我不太明白这一切是如何运作的，但对于某种视角来说，你可以得到一些海洋的东西，得到一些山脉。我想这应该足以作为一个描述，如果你进行渲染，以及背后那些我们为了节省时间而略过的魔法，你就可以重现电影中的样子。这显然是一场小组讨论的结果，当时有人问，为什么你们还在使用专有的东西？
what prevents you from using open source stuff? You know why? And their sort of response was, well, with the amount of data we have, just the open source stuff kind of doesn't really work. And most people don't demonstrate their academic research on the level of complexity that we have internally.
是什么阻止了你们使用开源的东西？你知道为什么吗？他们的回答大意是，以我们拥有的数据量，开源的东西其实不太管用。而且大多数人展示他们的学术研究时，并没有达到我们内部那种复杂程度。
So it's often sort of not useful to us. And so they took that as an internal challenge that like, hey, what we ought to do is release an example of sophistication level we use for a production movie, so that the community has a chance to understand what it's like. And it turns out for sort of naive pass at like rendering it. And it takes, you know, I forget, upwards of several hours. And in fact, actually, they tried to do it on their home computer. And it never finished due to basically thrashing, trying to use virtual memory to hold it all just to load the description. It ran out of memory. And so this person, apparently that these blog articles, P-H-A-R-R.org. Anyways, go to the show notes or I guess maybe use your Google food to find it. This person, I don't know the full context here, but it seems like they interned at Pixar
所以这对我们来说通常没什么用。于是他们把它当作一个内部挑战，觉得应该发布一个我们用于制作电影的复杂程度的示例，让社区有机会了解它是怎样的。结果发现，对于这种渲染的简单尝试，它需要，我忘了，长达几个小时。事实上，他们尝试在自己的家用电脑上运行，但由于虚拟内存不足以加载描述，系统一直在“抖动”，最终从未完成。所以这个人，显然这些博客文章来自P-H-A-R-R.org。总之，去看看节目备注，或者用谷歌搜一下。这个人，我不知道完整的背景，但看起来他们曾在皮克斯
or Disney for a while. So they had some insight to how the internal tooling work. Can they have some anecdotes about that? But they're trying to do this externally. It doesn't seem that they you know work there now and it just sort of goes through various things that they're doing trying to speed up the loading doing some optimizations and um it's a very interesting read uh just about how rendering works how really big all this is how complicated it is not per se to load it up and do it myself um but also one of
或迪士尼实习过一段时间。所以他们对内部工具的运作方式有一些了解。他们有一些相关的轶事。但他们是在外部尝试做这件事。看起来他们现在不在那里工作，文章里讲述了他们为了加快加载速度所做的各种优化。这是一篇非常有趣的读物，关于渲染是如何工作的，这一切有多么庞大和复杂。虽然不是为了自己加载和运行，但其中
the things that in the i actually found this via uh y combinator news hacker news and one of the top comments on there i thought was really good and insightful and reading this i i like that person's comment which was uh you see that even in something as sophisticated as these people are and experts at rendering and making production movies like Moana and state of the art and all this stuff that you find out some of the reasons things are slow and that they had to fix were things like they have only a 256 entry hash map and they use string names of texture maps to go into that hash map in which there are far more than 256 as things have grown. And furthermore, the hashing function was legacy from a long time ago and chosen just to take the first character of the string as your names have gotten so long uh in the modern movies that often they almost
一件事——我实际上是通过Y Combinator的Hacker News发现的——其中一条热门评论我觉得非常好且有见地。读到这里，我喜欢那个人的评论，他说：你看到即使是在像这些人这样精通渲染和制作像《海洋奇缘》这样的电影的专家中，在最先进的技术中，你也会发现一些导致速度缓慢的原因，他们不得不修复的东西，比如他们只有一个256个条目的哈希映射，他们使用纹理贴图的字符串名称进入该哈希映射，而随着事物的发展，纹理贴图的数量远不止256个。此外，哈希函数是很久以前遗留下来的，仅仅选择了字符串的第一个字符。随着现代电影中名称变得越来越长，它们通常几乎
all began with dot dot dot slash something as like a shortening of the string name due to some other implications so every single entry into the hash map was going into exactly the same bucket and just becoming a big link list traversal and amazing so they were sort of you know not being mean just pointing out that like hey even experts make sort of entry level mistakes, organic growth. It's actually complex problems can still boil down to relatively simple things and issue and just incremental and building up a body of knowledge over time. Complexity arises, but that each individual problem really is sort of you know this attainable amount like just figuring out why hashing is slow is something that seems more manageable in your mind than how to render all of the Moana Island scene for a production movie studio yeah do you think that
都以“.../”开头，作为字符串名称的缩写，由于其他一些含义，所以进入哈希映射的每一个条目都进入了同一个桶，变成了一个巨大的链表遍历。太神奇了。所以他们并不是在刻薄，只是指出即使是专家也会犯入门级的错误，这是有机增长的结果。实际上，复杂的问题仍然可以归结为相对简单的事情，以及随着时间的推移积累知识。复杂性确实会出现，但每个单独的问题在你的脑海中似乎都是可控的，比如弄清楚为什么哈希很慢，这比弄清楚如何为电影工作室渲染整个《海洋奇缘》岛屿场景要容易管理得多。是的，你认为
maybe when Disney released the information that like they had already kind of unfolded it in some way where it's not efficient anymore? You know what I mean? It's sort of like releasing, like, if you had a protobuf, instead of releasing the.proto file, you released all the C++ code, right? Sure, yeah. So a couple of comments. I think some of these were anecdotes from internal Pixar work that they were sort of saying, not specific to this exact thing. But you're also right. So one of the things they talk about, I think that is sort of the point is that when Disney converted this to this other format, is this other format doesn't have the same level of optimizations because it's not used to dealing with scenes this big. So Disney works at a scale that this PBRT, or at least sort of reading through this and my sort of opinion on it, is like Disney works at scenes,
当迪士尼发布这些信息时，他们是否已经以某种方式将其展开，导致它不再高效了？你明白我的意思吗？这就像是发布，如果你有一个protobuf，你没有发布.proto文件，而是发布了所有的C++代码，对吧？当然，是的。所以有几点评论。我认为其中一些是来自皮克斯内部工作的轶事，他们是在说，并非针对这件具体的事情。但你也是对的。所以他们谈论的一件事，我认为这正是重点，即当迪士尼将其转换为这种其他格式时，这种格式并没有相同水平的优化，因为它不习惯处理这么大的场景。所以迪士尼的工作规模，这种PBRT——或者至少通过阅读这些内容以及我的看法——是迪士尼处理的场景，
so several orders of magnitude more complicated than most of the PBRT rendering scenes. And so, yeah, they do have to unpack some of this stuff into very verbose structures. And so part of what this person did in these articles is do things like a more efficient representations of the triangles for meshes that brought down like the file size by you know half or something because exactly that and then you know trying to say hey how do we
比大多数PBRT渲染场景复杂几个数量级。所以，是的，他们确实必须将其中一些东西解包成非常冗长的结构。所以这个人在这几篇文章中所做的一部分工作就是做一些事情，比如对网格的三角形进行更有效的表示，这使文件大小减少了一半左右，正是因为这个原因。然后，你知道，试图说，嘿，我们如何
open source this and i think that was kind of part of this whole discussion between disney and the open source community is like yeah you guys your level of sophistication isn't where we need it to be in order for us to sort of share technologies between each other. And so, yeah, I do think it's what you're saying, which is they have to unpack this binary custom format into a very verbose open source thing. But the open source thing is that verbose because it's more simple to do initially
开源这个东西？我认为这是迪士尼和开源社区之间整个讨论的一部分，即：是的，你们的复杂程度还没有达到我们需要共享技术的水平。所以，是的，我确实认为这就是你所说的，他们必须将这种二进制自定义格式解包成一个非常冗长的开源东西。但那个开源的东西之所以那么冗长，是因为最初这样做更简单，
and no one needed that scale yet right yeah that makes sense so it's not someone did something wrong it's just it just is the way it is yeah it totally makes sense i mean it's cool that they sort of started that conversation i mean now like maybe there could be some sort of back and forth and eventually the open source community kind of catches up um my news is uh tedEd riddles. So this is really cool. I've been following TED and TED-Ed for a while. And this is a pretty new thing. Basically, what's going on here is they've gone and made a set of like kind of puzzles. I mean, there's a lot of these sort of what's the word like canonical or famous puzzles over the years.
而且还没有人需要那种规模，对吧？是的，这说得通。所以不是有人做错了什么，它就是这样。是的，这完全说得通。我的意思是，他们开启了那场对话很酷。我的意思是，现在也许可以有一些来回的交流，最终开源社区会赶上来。我的新闻是TED-Ed谜题。这真的很酷。我关注TED和TED-Ed有一段时间了。这是一个相当新的东西。基本上，这里发生的事情是他们制作了一系列谜题。我的意思是，多年来有很多这种，怎么说呢，经典的或著名的谜题。
They're not like, you know, crossword puzzles or things like that. They're really just kind of like simple mathematical puzzles. And TED-Ed has been producing a series of videos on these. They call it the TED-Ed riddles series. And these are so fun. I mean, they kind of like, you know, I don't really know what their cadence is. So it just seems like they kind of just serendipitously show up on my phone but it's always really interesting the most recent one it was basically the nim problem which is um uh the idea is you have a set of stones and you have an opponent it's a game your opponent has a set of stones and you can remove uh oh no sorry sorry
它们不像填字游戏之类的东西。它们真的只是简单的数学谜题。TED-Ed一直在制作一系列关于这些的视频。他们称之为TED-Ed谜题系列。这些非常有趣。我的意思是，他们，我真的不知道他们的节奏是什么。所以看起来他们只是偶然出现在我的手机上，但总是非常有趣。最近的一个基本上是尼姆博弈（Nim problem），即……这个想法是你有一组石头，你有一个对手，这是一个游戏。你的对手有一组石头，你可以移除……哦，不，抱歉，抱歉。
it's one set of stones among both between both of you and you can remove i oh no, sorry, sorry. It's one set of stones between both of you. And you can remove, I think, one, two, or three stones, one through end stones. And so then it becomes the opponent's turn. And he can remove, you know, some number of stones. And the person who takes the last stone loses, right? So like, for example, if there are two stones left, you can take one. And now the other person has to lose because he has to take one. And so it kind of explains. And so I think that the riddle is the riddle comes down to how many if can you tell from how many stones are in the pile who is going to win?
这是你们两人之间的一组石头，你可以移除，我想，一、二或三块石头，一到N块石头。然后就轮到对手了。他可以移除，你知道，一定数量的石头。拿走最后一块石头的人输了，对吧？所以，例如，如果剩下两块石头，你可以拿走一块。现在另一个人必须输，因为他必须拿走最后一块。所以它解释了这一点。所以我认为这个谜题归结为：你能从堆里有多少块石头判断出谁会赢吗？
And so, you know, obviously you could play it out. Like you could write some computer program that tries all the different, you know, strategies, but it was really more, the riddles more about like, is there some formula which could just tell you, you know, you know, do some simple arithmetic and then this person's going to win. And yeah, it's really cool. I mean, I won't spoil it, but there's a bunch of puzzles like this i think they're really fun and people should check them out do they give but they give the answers at the end oh yeah yeah right they give the answer so okay also it's um they uh when the problem is sort of scalable so like for example with this one they start off by asking you what would happen if
所以，你知道，显然你可以把它玩出来。你可以写一些计算机程序来尝试所有不同的策略，但谜题更多的是关于：是否存在某种公式，只需做一些简单的算术，就能告诉你这个人会赢。是的，这真的很酷。我的意思是，我不会剧透，但有很多这样的谜题，我觉得它们非常有趣，人们应该去看看。他们会在最后给出答案吗？哦，是的，是的，他们会给出答案。所以，好的，还有，当问题是可扩展的时候，比如这个，他们首先问你如果
there's two stones and then they wait five seconds and they tell you you know just take one of the stones right so they kind of walk you through it and at the end of it you kind of understand the problem so well very cool well time for book of the show book of the show my book of the show is aesop's fables so uh this is pretty random i mean i'm sure everyone knows that these are um I actually wanted to start, you know, reading them to my son. So I started checking it out. And I found this website, I think it's called free reads or free books, or something like that. But basically, I found an app which just had a huge catalog of free, you know, a lot of these like classic books. So like it doesn't really make sense to charge for, right?
有两块石头会发生什么，然后他们等五秒钟，告诉你，你知道，只需拿走一块石头，对吧？所以他们会引导你完成它，最后你就能很好地理解这个问题。非常酷。好吧，节目书目时间。我的节目书目是《伊索寓言》。所以，这很随机。我的意思是，我相信每个人都知道这些是……我实际上想开始读给我儿子听。所以我开始查看它。我找到了这个网站，我想它叫免费阅读或免费书籍之类的。但基本上，我找到了一个应用程序，它有一个巨大的免费经典书籍目录。所以，你知道，收费真的没意义，对吧？
And so I got Aesop's Fables and I was like, okay, let me just read through it. And yeah, they're all extremely morbid and end with death and animals killing each other. And I was really shocked. And then I realized, oh, what I thought were Aesop's Fables were actually the children's version of Aesop's Fables. And so I'm going to have to probably buy that. But yeah, it's interesting. I mean, one thing that Aesop's Fables, they're just much more harsh.
所以我拿到了《伊索寓言》，我想，好吧，让我读一遍。是的，它们都极其病态，以死亡和动物互相残杀告终。我真的很震惊。然后我意识到，哦，我以为是《伊索寓言》的东西实际上是儿童版的《伊索寓言》。所以我可能得买那个。但是的，这很有趣。我的意思是，有一件事是《伊索寓言》确实要严酷得多。
Like, for example, you have this story about, I think it's the ant and the grasshopper. But basically, i might be messing that up the animals but but basically there's one animal one insect that's sort of like saving food saving food saving food during the summer and the other one is just playing all summer and just eating grass off the ground and playing and then when winter comes the one who's been saving the food has enough food to survive the winter right and so the whole story is like when times are good save up kind of thing right well like as i remember in the children's version you know the the one who didn't save up you know was really hungry and then the first one gave him food
例如，你有一个关于，我想是蚂蚁和蚱蜢的故事。但基本上，我可能搞错了动物，但基本上有一只动物，一只昆虫，在夏天一直在存食物，存食物，存食物，而另一只整个夏天都在玩，只是吃地上的草，玩耍。然后冬天来了，存食物的那只就有足够的食物度过冬天，对吧？所以整个故事就是：当日子好过的时候，要存钱，那种感觉，对吧？好吧，正如我记得在儿童版中，你知道，那只没存食物的，你知道，非常饿，然后第一只给了他食物
to last them through the winter and he learned his lesson but in the actual fable uh the one who played all summer died and the other one ate him uh no that would be uh even more morbid um but no they're just like and then you know the grasshopper like withered away and died i was like what so uh either way uh actually if you if you've only read the children's version this version was pretty interesting um i would definitely read it um otherwise i mean it's always good to to read these fables they have like good stories at the end and things like that so so was aesop's fables originally those were the children's versions and we've just made them less harsh for current children that's right okay well i i don't know if you know if we were to go
让他度过冬天，他吸取了教训。但在真正的寓言中，那只玩了一整个夏天的死了，另一只吃了他。不，那会更病态。但没有，它们只是像，然后你知道，蚱蜢枯萎而死。我当时想，什么？所以，无论如何，实际上如果你只读过儿童版，这个版本非常有趣。我肯定会读它。否则，我的意思是，阅读这些寓言总是好的，它们最后有很好的故事之类的。所以《伊索寓言》最初是儿童版，而我们只是让它们对现在的孩子来说不那么严酷了？没错。好的，好吧，我不知道如果我们回到
back to i think it's like greek times or something but i don't know if they uh read them to children or if they were actually fables that were told by two adults and then you know we started teaching them to children i don't really know like kind of how that progressed okay um but yeah they're either way yeah they're pretty harsh cool my book of the show is the blinding knife by brent weeks this is the second book in the i believe it's called the black prison no the black prison was the first book what is the name lightbringer uh trilogy and i really enjoyed it uh second books of trilogies can sometimes be uh whatever they call like sophomore slump i guess like it's a little difficult because it's not the final book where you can have all the good endings it's not the final book where you can have all the good endings.
希腊时代之类的，但我不知道他们是否读给孩子听，或者它们实际上是成年人讲的寓言，然后我们开始教给孩子。我真的不知道它是如何发展的。好的，但无论如何，它们确实相当严酷。酷。我的节目书目是布伦特·威克斯的《光之刃》（The Blinding Knife）。这是我认为叫《黑棱镜》（The Black Prism）——不，《黑棱镜》是第一本书。书名是什么？《光使者》（Lightbringer）三部曲。我真的很喜欢它。三部曲的第二本书有时会被称为，他们叫什么，第二部低谷（sophomore slump）？我想，这有点困难，因为它不是你可以有所有美好结局的最后一本书。
It's not the beginning book where you're introducing the world. It's like the in-between. But this second book, I was listening to it, as I always do, but I just say reading. Anyway, so I was listening to it, and I just found myself like the whole book, you know, pulled forward through the story. Oftentimes, which is not a bad thing but often there are books where you sort of have periods where you're like oh okay that was good and now
它不是介绍世界的开篇之作。它就像中间部分。但这本书，我一直在听，像我平时做的那样，但我只是说阅读。总之，我一直在听，我发现自己整本书都被故事吸引着向前走。通常情况下，这不是坏事，但经常有书你会有一段时间觉得，哦，好吧，那很好，现在
i'm in sort of like a respite period or we're just you know building up their characters or a slow scene or whatever the pacing but this book i just i didn't feel like it was frenetic pace but it's just always like oh i can't wait to see what happens and when you have these stories from multiple points of view uh sometimes you find like no i don't want to leave this person's point of view and go listen to that other boring storyline but in this time i always felt like that was like no don't leave now i want to find out what happens and they would go to another point of view but then i would get really into that one and be like no don't leave that one to go back and it was just every time it switched perspectives i was just you know really into it which and be like, no, don't leave that one to go back. And it was just every time it switched perspectives, I was just really into it, which in thinking about it later was like, wow, OK, I really enjoyed the book.
我处于某种休息期，或者我们只是在塑造角色，或者节奏缓慢的场景。但这本书，我并没有觉得它是疯狂的节奏，但总是觉得，哦，我迫不及待想看看会发生什么。当你从多个视角讲述这些故事时，有时你会觉得，不，我不想离开这个人的视角去听那个无聊的故事线。但这次，我总是觉得，不，现在别走，我想找出发生了什么。他们会切换到另一个视角，但我会真正投入到那个视角中，觉得，不，别离开那个去回看。每次切换视角时，我都非常投入。后来回想起来，觉得，哇，好吧，我真的很喜欢这本书。
Regardless of even the fact that the story was good or that I found the world interesting, I was just finding that the pacing of it made me sort of want to finish. In fact, I normally don't listen unless I'm commuting, but I actually listened to finish it when I wasn't on a commute because I was like the last couple hours. I just really wanted to get through. That's awesome. So I really enjoyed that. Of course, I would start with book number one, The Black Prism of the Lightbringer series before reading book two. And if you like that, then definitely continue on to the second book. I don't don't I haven't finished the trilogy yet, so I guess stay tuned.
不管故事好不好，或者我觉得世界是否有趣，我只是发现它的节奏让我想要读完。事实上，我通常只在通勤时听，但我实际上在非通勤时间听完了它，因为我想在最后几个小时读完。这太棒了。所以我真的很喜欢。当然，我会从第一本书《光使者》系列的《黑棱镜》开始，然后再读第二本。如果你喜欢那个，那么一定要继续读第二本。我还没有读完三部曲，所以我想敬请期待。
But the good news is, unlike a lot of trilogies, this trilogy is finished. So the third book is out. I just haven't listened to it yet. So no need to worry. This is a new thing now where people refuse to start series before they're finished because it seems like so many authors are not finishing off their series. That makes sense. So the did any of these paths intertwine? Or is it all going to happen in the third book? Um, no. Oh, so yeah, so some of the story point of views do intertwine with each
但好消息是，与许多三部曲不同，这个三部曲已经完成了。所以第三本书已经出来了。我只是还没听。所以不用担心。现在有一种新现象，人们拒绝在系列完成之前开始阅读，因为似乎很多作者都没有完成他们的系列。这说得通。那么这些路径有交织吗？还是所有事情都会在第三本书中发生？嗯，没有。哦，所以，是的，一些故事视角确实与
other. It's not one of these ones where you're like, I don't even know how these stories relate. Like, it's, it's pretty clear how the different stories relate to each other in this specific series. Okay, cool. And this is just for people who didn't catch the first one. This is a fantasy series where there's magic and the magic is sort of related to color of light, like the spectrum of light. So people are able to use magic based on some colors. Like some people might be able to use red light to make magic and some people blue light.
彼此交织。它不是那种让你觉得“我甚至不知道这些故事有什么关系”的系列。在这个特定的系列中，不同故事之间的关系非常清楚。好的，酷。这只是给那些没赶上第一本的人说的，这是一个奇幻系列，有魔法，魔法与光的颜色有关，比如光谱。所以人们能够基于某些颜色使用魔法。比如有些人可能能够使用红光制造魔法，有些人使用蓝光。
And each of those have sort of characteristics about them. And it's just a sort of interesting take on magic system. So is it literally light? So they have a flashlight to help them with magic or something? So it's, I guess, not set in times when there's flashlights, but they do have is not a big spoiler. So they sort of talk about, you know, only a very special set of people that have special meaning in the in the world can use white light and sort of split the light. And hence the name prism. Normal people have to use reflected light of their color. So like if you're a green person, you can be outside and you can absorb the green light reflecting off of the grass. But then also they invented the ability to make spectacles like glasses that are tinted.
每种颜色都有其特征。这是一个有趣的魔法系统。所以它是字面意义上的光吗？他们有手电筒来帮助他们使用魔法吗？所以，我想，它不是设定在有手电筒的时代，但他们确实有——这不是大剧透。所以他们谈论，你知道，只有一小部分在世界上有特殊意义的特殊人群可以使用白光，并把光分开。因此得名“棱镜”（Prism）。普通人必须使用他们颜色的反射光。所以如果你是一个绿色的人，你可以在外面，你可以吸收从草地上反射的绿光。但后来他们也发明了制作有色眼镜的能力。
So that if you have your spectacles on, then you can absorb green light directly from sort of white light. Oh, I see. And so there's some clever stuff in there about that. I don't want to say too much without sort of white light oh i see and so there's some some clever stuff in there about that i don't want to say too much without sort of sure sure of spoiling it but um wait it actually says book two of five now i'm confused what is this oh i guess maybe there's some in between books oh sometimes they do that right like there's a side side story that's optional okay well i might be wrong about this series and maybe it's not a trilogy maybe i thought it was a trilogy and it's a quintology i i don't have time to read this right now so i withdraw my earlier statement until further review you're gonna unread these two books
所以如果你戴上眼镜，你就可以直接从白光中吸收绿光。哦，我明白了。里面有一些聪明的东西。我不想在不剧透的情况下说太多。但等等，它现在实际上写着五部曲中的第二部，我现在很困惑。这是什么？哦，我想也许中间有一些书。哦，有时他们会那样做，对吧？比如有一个可选的支线故事。好的，好吧，我可能对这个系列错了，也许它不是三部曲，也许我以为它是三部曲，但它是五部曲。我现在没时间读这个，所以我撤回我之前的陈述，直到进一步审查。你要取消阅读这两本书吗？
until i thought it was a trilogy but this is not the first time this has happened to me i'm very confused are all five books done or no so there are currently okay i'm just clicking on the amazon page and it says book four of five just came out last year oh i see okay uh so i never mind so i retract my earlier statement do not start this well it's pretty it's pretty sure he'll finish the fifth book i mean it seems like he's doing a book a year roughly uh yeah so the yeah one year one year two years two years so yeah cool so yeah i think you could start reading knowing that it'll be done i don't know i'm not yeah i'm not getting this is a whole rabbit trail of okay moving on moving on um so if you if you want to
直到我以为它是三部曲，但这已经不是第一次发生在我身上了。我很困惑。这五本书都写完了吗？还是没有？所以目前，好的，我正在点击亚马逊页面，上面写着五部曲中的第四部去年刚出来。哦，我明白了。好的，好吧，没关系。所以我撤回我之前的陈述。不要开始读这个。好吧，他肯定会完成第五本书。我的意思是，看起来他大约一年出一本书。是的，所以，一年，一年，两年，两年。所以，是的，酷。所以，是的，我想你可以开始阅读，知道它会完成。我不知道，我不是……这完全是一个兔子洞，好的，继续，继续。嗯，所以如果你想
read four out of those five books you can do it on audible um check out audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown i'm still going through basic economics but i did buy uh super intelligence and that's going to be next wait that sounds like a good book is it gonna help me yeah no spoilers we can't spoil it actually just plugs in it plugs into your brain Ooh. It's a bionic book. So, yeah. But I've been reading out Basic Economics or listening to it on the shuttle. And actually, I have a pretty long walk now because I end up walking about a mile and a half before I hop on the shuttle. And I've been listening to it on my walk as well.
阅读那五本书中的四本，你可以在Audible上读。去看看audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。我还在读《基础经济学》，但我确实买了《超级智能》，那将是下一本。等等，那听起来是一本好书。它会帮助我吗？是的，没有剧透。我们不能剧透。实际上它直接插入你的大脑。噢。这是一个仿生书。所以，是的。但我一直在读《基础经济学》，或者在班车上听。实际上，我现在有一段很长的路要走，因为我在上班车前要走大约一英里半。我也在走路时听它。
Oh, hey. That's pretty good. Yeah, it's not too bad. Cool bad cool also you can support us on patreon patreon.com programming throwdown and uh make a donation for each time we release an episode and we've that's been growing pretty good so thank you to all of our patrons yes that's right uh thanks to all our patrons and your continued support yeah and uh you know i hope you like the uh christmas present um we'll figure out what to do for international folks but yeah don't. And, uh, you know, hope you like the, uh, Christmas present. Um, we'll, we'll figure out what to do for international folks,
哦，嘿。那很不错。是的，还不赖。酷，坏，酷。另外，你可以在Patreon上支持我们，patreon.com/programmingthrowdown，并且每次我们发布一集时捐款。这增长得相当不错，所以感谢我们所有的赞助人。是的，没错。感谢我们所有的赞助人以及你们的持续支持。是的，而且，你知道，我希望你喜欢圣诞礼物。我们会想办法处理国际听众的问题，但是的，不要。而且，你知道，希望你喜欢圣诞礼物。嗯，我们会想办法处理国际听众的问题，
but yeah, domestic, um, yeah, domestic, you know, uh, uh,
但是的，国内的，嗯，是的，国内的，你知道，嗯，嗯，
hopefully you like the Christmas present. Uh, we, we take all the money and we use it to, you know, get more people on the show, pay for server costs, pay for microphones,
希望你喜欢圣诞礼物。嗯，我们把所有的钱都拿来，我们用它来，你知道，让更多的人上节目，支付服务器费用，支付麦克风费用，
do all this stuff, figure out a way to get discord to work. Um, might have to buy like some third party thing, but, uh, uh, but the rest of it, we it we try to like you know dole it back out so um cool thanks for supporting us there on to tool of the show show my tool this show is tensorboard um so this is pretty cool it's actually starting to become decoupled from TensorFlow. So I'll give a bit of background.
做所有这些事情，想办法让Discord工作。嗯，可能得买一些第三方的东西，但，嗯，嗯，但剩下的部分，我们尝试，你知道，把它分发回去。所以，酷，感谢你们在那里的支持。进入节目工具环节。我的节目工具是TensorBoard。所以，这很酷。它实际上开始与TensorFlow解耦了。所以我先介绍一点背景。
TensorFlow is a library for doing, it's basically like a BLAS on steroids. So BLAS is like a linear algebra. It stands for basic linear algebra system. And so the idea is, let's say you need to add two vectors. So you have two lists of numbers that are the same length, and you need to add, you know, pairwise add each of these numbers, or pointwise add each of these numbers, right? You could write a for loop, and you could say, you know,
TensorFlow是一个用于执行的库，它基本上就像是类固醇上的BLAS。所以BLAS就像线性代数。它代表基础线性代数系统。所以这个想法是，假设你需要加两个向量。所以你有两个长度相同的数字列表，你需要加，你知道，成对加这些数字，或者逐点加这些数字，对吧？你可以写一个for循环，你可以说，你知道，
yeah, C of I equals A of I plus B of I, right? But that's not that fast, right? And so when you start doing a lot of this, you know, you're adding vectors, you're multiplying vectors, you're doing the tensor product, you're doing all these matrix operations, the speed becomes really, really important because chances are this is the code that is going to take most of the time
是的，C[i]等于A[i]加B[i]，对吧？但这并不快，对吧？所以当你开始做很多这种事情时，你知道，你在加向量，你在乘向量，你在做张量积，你在做所有这些矩阵运算，速度变得非常非常重要，因为很有可能这就是将占用大部分时间的代码
whenever you're building one of these type of systems, right? So for a while there was Blaz and it's still around, but then people started building kind of on top of that. And TensorFlow is one of these sort of super libraries. So it could do all the Blast stuff. It could also run on the GPU. There's also a whole bunch of like kind of specific scientific functions. And it comes with this thing called TensorFlow board.
无论你何时构建这些类型的系统，对吧？所以有一段时间有BLAS，它仍然存在，但后来人们开始在它之上构建。TensorFlow就是这些超级库之一。所以它可以做所有的BLAS工作。它也可以在GPU上运行。还有一大堆特定的科学函数。它带有一个叫做TensorFlow Board的东西。
So you can, similar to like the MATLAB environment, you can kind of easily plot things and things like that. So you can, you know, on the GPU, do a bunch of matrix operations, and then you could plot the result. It'll actually copy it back to your CPU and then kind of render it, right? And TensorBoard is awesome. It's got a great user interface. It's awesome visualization. And so what you're seeing is the open source community just adopt TensorBoard, really just independent of TensorFlow.
所以你可以，类似于MATLAB环境，你可以很容易地绘制东西之类的。所以你可以，你知道，在GPU上做一堆矩阵运算，然后你可以绘制结果。它实际上会把它复制回你的CPU，然后渲染它，对吧？TensorBoard很棒。它有一个很棒的用户界面。它是很棒的可视化。所以你看到的是开源社区只是采用了TensorBoard，真的只是独立于TensorFlow。
So there's this thing called TensorBoardX. And I've also seen like OpenTensorBoard and a couple other things. I believe TensorFlow is actually going to upstream one of these implementations or some hybrid of them. And the net result is, you know, if you have a chunk of data and you don't even need to have made this data with TensorFlow, it could be something you made in your web server or something like that.
所以有一个东西叫TensorBoardX。我也见过像OpenTensorBoard和其他一些东西。我相信TensorFlow实际上将上游实现其中一个实现或它们的某种混合。最终的结果是，你知道，如果你有一块数据，你甚至不需要用TensorFlow制作这些数据，它可能是你在Web服务器或其他东西上制作的东西。
You can write this data to a specific file format using this TensorBoardX. And then you can use the TensorBoard to sort of visualize that data. So it's disconnected from the rest of TensorFlow. And yeah, I started using this a couple of days ago. It's pretty cool. You know, I mean, if you're using something like MATLAB, it's pretty easy to graph things. But if you're writing just a desktop program, it might not be obvious, like, You know, I mean, if you're using something like MATLAB, it's pretty easy to graph things. But if you're writing just a desktop program, it might not be obvious. Like, you know, how do I, you know, how do I dump data to a file that then I look at in a graph format pretty easily? You know, often people will dump it to, let's say, CSV and then they'll use Excel to look at it. I mean, that's OK. But this this I think is going to be a lot better when it's ready. That sounds pretty cool. I mean, visualizing always helps. I just like it. And
你可以使用这个TensorBoardX将这些数据写入特定的文件格式。然后你可以使用TensorBoard来可视化这些数据。所以它与TensorFlow的其余部分断开了连接。是的，我几天前开始使用这个。它很酷。你知道，我的意思是，如果你使用像MATLAB这样的东西，绘制图表很容易。但如果你只是写一个桌面程序，它可能不明显，比如，你知道，我的意思是，如果你使用像MATLAB这样的东西，绘制图表很容易。但如果你只是写一个桌面程序，它可能不明显。比如，你知道，我如何，你知道，我如何将数据转储到文件中，然后我很容易地以图表格式查看它？你知道，人们通常会把它转储到，比如CSV，然后他们会使用Excel来查看它。我的意思是，那还可以。但我认为这个在准备好时会好得多。这听起来很酷。我的意思是，可视化总是有帮助的。我只是喜欢它。而且
there just always helps. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you know, this idea that like, oh, there's no compiler errors. I'm done. Yeah, that doesn't really work. I mean, not only for the stuff I do, but just in general. I mean, you know, for example, let's say you're building a website. Some number of people are going to, let's say, like their browser is going to crash on your website. It doesn't mean it's your fault. They might have viruses on their computer. Who knows, right? But you want to be able to plot that and see what that looks like.
总是有帮助的。是的。是的。我的意思是，你知道，这个想法是，哦，没有编译器错误。我完成了。是的，那真的不管用。我的意思是，不仅对我做的事情，而且总的来说。我的意思是，你知道，例如，假设你正在构建一个网站。一定数量的人会，比如，他们的浏览器会在你的网站上崩溃。这并不意味着是你的错。他们的电脑上可能有病毒。谁知道呢，对吧？但你想能够绘制它并看看它是什么样子。
So it's like, well, anything you do is going to involve dumping out some data and looking at it and uh you know excel is just not really i mean you could do it but it's not really made for that um this this thing is really made for that nice yeah i mean i think visualization and telling that story is always you know super critical for people understanding the work you're doing yep yeah totally well my app is much less cool than that it's a game surprise usual sproggy would i don't know if it's how you say it s-p-r-o-g-g-i yeah i've played this game actually oh you have oh good i picked one you know about yeah that's right so this is available i guess also on the computer but on both ios and android it's about five dollars
所以就像，好吧，你做的任何事情都将涉及转储一些数据并查看它，而且，你知道，Excel真的不是，我的意思是，你可以这样做，但它真的不是为此而生的。嗯，这个东西真的是为此而生的。不错。是的，我的意思是，我认为可视化和讲述那个故事总是，你知道，对人们理解你正在做的工作至关重要。是的。是的，完全正确。好吧，我的应用程序比那个酷得多。这是一个游戏。惊喜。通常Sproggy会……我不知道这是不是你说的，S-P-R-O-G-G-I。是的，我实际上玩过这个游戏。哦，你玩过？哦，好。我选了一个你知道的。是的，没错。所以这个可以在电脑上玩，但在iOS和Android上都有，大约五美元。
um and this is uh well i guess you would call a rogue like um where there's uh it's a kind of a turn-based game but you kind of don't it's not as turn-based as other games so you sort of get to make a move then the world makes a move and you make a move and you're on a grid of squares and you try to defeat the bad guys and move around sort of randomly generated levels that have a theme and progress your people and you will die a lot or at least i die a lot uh and then but you get to sort of keep your gold buy things to improve sort of level up your characters uh and they have a variety of different sort of classes you can play as and i for me this is one of those things where i really like i found
嗯，这是，嗯，好吧，我想你会称之为Roguelike，其中有，它是一种回合制游戏，但你有点，它不像其他游戏那样回合制。所以你得到一个移动的机会，然后世界移动，你移动，你在一个方格网格上，你试图击败坏人，在某种随机生成的有主题的关卡中移动，并提升你的人员。你会死很多次，或者至少我死很多次。然后，但你得到，你知道，保留你的金币，购买东西来改进，提升你的角色等级。他们有各种不同的职业你可以扮演。对我来说，这是其中之一，我真的很喜欢，我发现
not so much liking games uh on the on ios that are sort of big epic games i mean they're good i just find it i prefer to just kind of play those on my computer or console and i guess this is me uh and there are some most people are like that yeah i i believe so although i mean it's becoming easier to play like i have a my ipad now i do have some games on that i sit down and play with it it's becoming more like it but anyways but this fills that kind of i want to play something more than just like a solitaire game or whatever but not a super in-depth game and so i want to be able to play in sort of two to five minutes like a session or whatever and this fits right into that
不太喜欢iOS上的游戏，那些大型史诗游戏。我的意思是，它们很好，我只是发现我更喜欢在我的电脑或主机上玩那些。我想这就是我。而且大多数人都是那样。是的，我相信如此。虽然，我的意思是，玩游戏变得更容易了，比如我现在的iPad，我上面确实有一些游戏，我坐下来玩。它变得越来越像了。但无论如何，但这填补了那种我想要玩点东西，不仅仅是像纸牌游戏之类的，但不是一个超级深入的游戏。所以我想要能够在，你知道，两到五分钟内玩，比如一个会话之类的，这正适合我。
that sweet spot for me yep yeah it's actually technically a rogue light which means uh you know in a rogue like game you start from scratch every time oh okay so what you know that's uh it's it's it's fun but it can also feel kind of frustrating because the only thing that you get in between games is some knowledge if anything right um with rogue lights it's sort of like when you die you get something permanent and eventually those permanent things you'll get so much of them that even if you aren't that good at the game you'll eventually be like overpowered let's say relative to where you're at and so i actually like rogue lights a lot better because it gives the game uh the game developer a lot more freedom so you know he can make a section that's really difficult and if people can't really
那个甜蜜点。是的，它实际上在技术上是一个Roguelite，这意味着，你知道，在Roguelike游戏中，你每次都从零开始。哦，好的。所以你知道，那是，它很有趣，但它也会让人感到沮丧，因为你在游戏之间得到的唯一东西就是知识，如果有的话，对吧？对于Roguelite，它有点像当你死时，你得到一些永久的东西，最终那些永久的东西你会得到很多，即使你不擅长游戏，你最终也会，比如，相对于你所处的位置变得过于强大。所以我实际上更喜欢Roguelite，因为它给了游戏开发者更多的自由。所以，你知道，他可以制作一个非常困难的部分，如果人们不能真正……
figure out how to get around it they can kind of just grind through it versus a rogue like a game I mean there's games like dungeon crawl stone soup where people have been playing for like eight years and they can't beat it you know so uh um but yeah i thought sproggy wood was uh was awesome i didn't actually finish the game but i got pretty far and yeah i i really love the way they did it um for people don't know the roguelike sort of style it's basically kind of like a grid and it's kind of frozen when you're not doing anything which works really well on mobile because like you can kind of think for a little bit you could pause the game is effectively paused all the time but then when you do something for however long it takes for that action to take
找出绕过它的方法，他们可以硬着头皮闯过去，而不像 Roguelike 游戏。我的意思是，像《Dungeon Crawl Stone Soup》这样的游戏，人们玩了八年都通不了关。不过，我觉得《Sproggiwood》真的很棒，虽然我没通关，但玩得挺深入的。我真的很喜欢他们的设计方式。对于不了解 Roguelike 风格的人来说，它基本上就像一个网格，当你什么都不做时，游戏是静止的，这在移动端效果很好，因为你可以思考一会儿，游戏实际上一直处于暂停状态，但当你执行某个动作时，无论该动作需要多长时间，
place that's when the world is sort of elapsing yep so if you've never tried one check this one out there are other ones too if you've never experienced one, check this one out. There are other ones too, if you've never experienced that genre. Yeah, totally. Cool. Well, this episode, we decided to do a mailbag. It's been a while since we've done one. And so we collected questions that have come in over the last day slash month slash several months. So first we're gonna start with some email questions.
世界才会随之推进。是的，如果你从没试过，可以去看看。还有其他类似的游戏，如果你从没体验过这种类型的话。是的，完全同意。酷。那么，这一集我们决定做一个问答环节。我们已经很久没做过了。所以我们收集了过去一天、一个月甚至几个月里收到的问题。首先，我们从一些电子邮件问题开始。
Some of these are actually just suggestions and tips you guys have sent in. And I've tried to just go down to first names or if people preferred something else. For Discord, they're just sort of handles. So hopefully the people who sent these in know we're talking about you. And many of the ones we've replied to already, but I thought they would be useful to put in here. And so we'll go through these. So first up is Nathan sent us an email about developing games in Lua
其中一些其实只是你们发来的建议和技巧。我尽量只用名字，或者如果人们有其他偏好就按偏好来。对于 Discord，它们只是某种昵称。所以希望发来这些内容的人知道我们在谈论你们。很多问题我们已经回复过了，但我认为把它们放在这里会很有用。所以我们来看看这些。首先是 Nathan 发给我们的关于用 Lua 开发游戏的邮件，
using Pico 8 and the Pocket Chip. So the Pocket Chip is a physical device that is, I guess, sort of like an Arduino, but maybe a little more in a different way where you more progress. It's sort of what you call like batteries included i guess like it has more to do with just the thing instead of needing to learn to build circuits and do stuff with uh and the pico 8 is actually uh i guess oh you just call like an emulator it's a
使用 Pico-8 和 Pocket Chip。Pocket Chip 是一种物理设备，我想它有点像 Arduino，但可能在某种程度上有所不同，你会有更多进展。它有点像所谓的“开箱即用”，我的意思是，它更多地与设备本身有关，而不是需要学习如何构建电路之类的东西。而 Pico-8 其实是……我想你称之为模拟器，它是一个
console that just is a program but you write programs for that program like levels and stuff and games in lua and then you can sort of email those quote-unquote cartridges to other people to play on their Pico-8s. I had never seen that before. It actually seems pretty cool. Oh, I thought the Pico-8 was also a physical thing, isn't it? I don't think so. Oh, interesting.
控制台，只是一个程序，但你为那个程序编写程序，比如关卡、游戏之类的，用 Lua 编写，然后你可以把那些所谓的“卡带”通过电子邮件发给其他人，在他们的 Pico-8 上玩。我以前从没见过这个。它看起来确实很酷。哦，我以为 Pico-8 也是一种物理设备，不是吗？我不这么认为。哦，有意思。
Oh, okay. So you also didn't know about this. I guess I was thrown off when I saw the pictures. Oh, okay. Um, so the pocket chip has like a keyboard and a screen attached to it. Uh, and I haven't checked into it since it first came out about, I guess probably a little over a year ago. Um, and I knew it was like getting pretty popular and it was like sold out and I just
哦，好吧。所以你也不知道这个。我想我看到图片时被误导了。哦，好吧。嗯，Pocket Chip 有键盘和屏幕连接在上面。嗯，自从它大约一年多前刚出来之后，我就没再关注过它了。嗯，我知道它变得很受欢迎，而且卖光了，我只是
never sort of ordered one, but I guess I should, because now that it's been long enough, there's probably a lot of cool stuff to do with it so yeah that sounds awesome thanks for that suggestion nathan very cool um dylan asks uh about modding video games i think uh yeah i mean i actually used to do this the first sort of programming i did was was way back in uh high school and uh i actually i don't know if this i guess this doesn't really count as modding because it was an open source but remember those mods? Those text based mods? Sure.
一直没订购一个，但我想我应该订购，因为现在时间够久了，可能有很多很酷的玩法。所以，听起来太棒了，谢谢你的建议，Nathan，非常酷。嗯，Dylan 问关于修改（modding）电子游戏的事，我想……嗯，是的，其实我以前做过这个。我最早做的编程是在高中时期，嗯，其实我不知道这算不算修改，因为它是一个开源项目，但还记得那些模组吗？那些基于文本的模组？当然。
So yeah, basically just they were all open source so I just made a version of those where you could make your own items and so it's one of these things that completely broke the whole game because the whole point of the game is to try to progress and get better items
所以，基本上它们都是开源的，所以我做了一个版本，你可以制作自己的物品，所以这是那种完全破坏了整个游戏的事情之一，因为游戏的全部意义在于尝试进步并获得更好的物品，
and so if you just make your own item it really doesn't matter but yeah that's kind of really how I started getting into programming was by kind of modding games I made some Starcraft maps with a bunch of these like they're these trigger based kind of like rule based language
所以如果你只是自己制作物品，那真的没意义。但确实，这就是我开始接触编程的方式，通过修改游戏。我用一些触发器（trigger）制作了一些《星际争霸》地图，它们是那种基于规则的语言，
and yeah I think it's a great way to get started with a bunch of these trigger-based, rule-based language. And yeah, I think it's a great way to get started. Also, the nice thing about modding video games is you don't have to worry about the art. So people kind of suspend belief on the art. So you could have a StarCraft character who's really supposed to be Mario, and just as long as you call him Mario, people kind of see okay this person was working with with what they had right um so so that that part is kind of nice and yeah i think it's super cool i think also it could get really complicated if you start actually trying to reverse engineer the game and stuff like that
是的，我认为这是开始学习这些基于触发器、基于规则的语言的好方法。而且，修改电子游戏的好处是你不需要担心美术。人们会选择性地忽略美术上的不足。所以你可以有一个本该是马里奥的《星际争霸》角色，只要你叫他马里奥，人们就会觉得“好吧，这个人是在现有条件下工作的”。嗯，所以那部分挺好的。而且，我觉得这超级酷。我也认为如果你真的开始尝试逆向工程游戏之类的东西，它可能会变得非常复杂。
yeah so in general i think modding video games is something you see a lot of programmers do i'll slightly disagree i think today there are better ways to get started than modding video games. If you're really passionate about it, perhaps. But I think using things like Unity or, and I know that's like a dirty word now, or like I guess Ogre now is trying to get better at this or we've talked about other sort of game engines and more environment setup i think there's pretty good other resources for sort of i don't say cobbling together but sort of hacking together all the framework and engine you need to start doing your own thing without a lot of the limitations that modding a game has um yeah that's a good point and so i i also have similar to one of the first things i started doing was trying to mod video games and, you know, use the Half-Life level editor to build levels. And yeah, I mean, I also did do a bunch of that when I got started as well, because I feel like writing a game from scratch was way harder or way less supporting resources you could get at the time. And so I'm curious now though, if that really is the best way, but it is definitely a way a lot of people sort of, I guess, Jason and I's era did get started.
是的，总的来说，我认为修改电子游戏是很多程序员都会做的事情。我稍微不同意，我认为今天有比修改电子游戏更好的入门方式。如果你真的对此充满热情，也许吧。但我认为使用像 Unity 这样的工具，我知道现在这可能不是个好词，或者像 Ogre 现在正试图在这方面做得更好，或者我们讨论过的其他游戏引擎和更多的环境设置，我认为有相当多不错的资源，可以用来——我不想说是拼凑，而是说黑客式地组合出你开始做自己事情所需的框架和引擎，而没有修改游戏所带来的许多限制。嗯，那是个好观点。我也和你有类似的经历，我开始做的事情之一就是尝试修改电子游戏，你知道，使用《半条命》关卡编辑器来构建关卡。是的，我的意思是，我刚开始时也做了很多这类事情，因为我觉得从零开始写一个游戏要难得多，或者当时支持的资源少得多。所以我现在很好奇，这是否真的是最好的方式，但这绝对是很多人——我想是 Jason 和我这一代人——开始的方式。
So I can't knock it. Yeah, I mean, I see your point. I think that like from a coding standpoint is definitely much easier. The issue is if you make a game kind of that's not a mod, people I think have different expectations. Oh, I see. That's the issue like especially on the art side is uh you know the expectations like if you make a minecraft mod everyone expects like if a pig is supposed to be you know a mech or something like that people
所以我不能否定它。是的，我明白你的意思。我认为从编码的角度来看，这绝对容易得多。问题是，如果你制作的游戏不是一个模组，人们会有不同的期望。哦，我明白了。这就是问题所在，特别是在美术方面，期望值很高。比如如果你制作一个《我的世界》模组，每个人都期望如果一只猪本该是一个机甲之类的东西，人们
say well you know okay yeah that's what the person had to work with fair point um but yeah i know i agree that like uh it's much easier to make a game now than it was when we were when we were doing it modding was pretty much your only option unless you wanted to spend a whole year writing really gnarly like open gl code and stuff like that i definitely go for a game that has a modding community and hopefully a good environment for it though rather than trying to reverse engineer if you're starting out yeah right and especially a way to sort of get feedback quickly a community the nice thing about starcraft was uh if you made a custom map for starcraft um you could just start
会说“好吧，好吧，那是那个人在现有条件下能做到的”，这很公平。嗯，但我同意，现在制作游戏比我们当时做的时候容易多了。修改游戏几乎是你唯一的选择，除非你想花一整年时间编写非常难搞的 OpenGL 代码之类的东西。如果刚开始的话，我绝对会选择一个有模组社区且环境良好的游戏，而不是尝试去逆向工程。是的，没错，特别是能快速获得反馈和社区支持的方式。星际争霸的好处是，如果你为星际争霸制作了一个自定义地图，
a a uh instance of that custom map people could look at the title and decide to join and then it would transfer the map to them automatically so it's like you don't have to worry about deployments finding a community all that stuff um but yeah i'm not up with it for modern day so no recommendations about current games that i'm same here okay so next one we have is david which uh he sent in a i'd never seen this before uh it seemed pretty useful although although it isn't particularly recent. This is aduni.org. And this was an Ars Digita University, which I guess ran 15, 20 years ago.
你可以启动该自定义地图的一个实例，人们可以看到标题并决定加入，然后它会自动将地图传输给他们，所以你不必担心部署、寻找社区等所有这些事情。但对于现代游戏我不太了解，所以没有关于当前游戏的推荐。我也是。好的，下一个是 David 发来的，我以前从没见过这个，它看起来很有用，尽管它不是特别新。这是 aduni.org。这是 Ars Digita 大学，我想它是 15、20 年前运行的。
That was a program where they would give you sort of a one-year super intensive, almost like a master's degree in computer science. And for fundamental stuff, he sort of recommends that they have all the courses uploaded. Similar, there are lots of other things that do this today. But this is sort of if you're interested in it from a kind of university perspective, or especially if you've gone to university and forgotten a lot of it, I guess this will have more familiarity to it than if you're learning from scratch. But I checked it out.
那是一个为期一年的超高强度项目，几乎相当于计算机科学的硕士学位。对于基础知识，他推荐了这个，因为他们上传了所有的课程。类似地，今天有很多其他东西也做这个。但如果你是从大学的角度感兴趣，或者特别是如果你上过大学但忘了很多东西，我想这会比从零开始学习更有熟悉感。但我看了一下。
It seems like I haven't gone and watched any of the videos yet, but there seemed to be a bunch of good stuff here. So, you know, I'm passing along that recommendation. Oh, very cool. Wow, this predates, you know, Coursera and Udacity and all of this. Wow, that's wild. It's amazing. Jack asks, how do we manage passwords?
看起来我还没去观看任何视频，但那里似乎有很多好东西。所以，我把这个推荐传达给你们。哦，非常酷。哇，这比 Coursera、Udacity 和所有这些都要早。哇，太疯狂了。太神奇了。Jack 问，我们如何管理密码？
That's a good question. I mean, I use KeePass. What do you use, Patrick? Like LastPass? No, I use, how do people do? I guess I, I don't know. I'm too cheap to pay or trust anyone. So yeah, I use KeePass and keep it synced with,
这是个好问题。我的意思是，我用 KeePass。你用什么，Patrick？比如 LastPass？不，我用……人们是怎么做的？我想我……我不知道。我太抠门了，不想付钱，也不信任任何人。所以是的，我用 KeePass 并保持同步，
I use this Resilio sync. It used to be BT sync and sync it between computers. So the database, which is encrypted with the, which I had to explain to, you know, I share it with my wife. And, you know, we use a very specific password that's not shared with anything else. It's much longer, much more secure. But then inside of there, we, and then we use its internal thing to generate new passwords. And we try to do that. And sometimes we'll, for less security things,
我用这个 Resilio Sync。它以前叫 BT Sync，在电脑之间同步。所以数据库是加密的，我必须向……你知道，我和我妻子共享它。而且，我们使用一个非常特殊的密码，不与任何其他东西共享。它更长，更安全。但在里面，我们使用它内置的功能来生成新密码。我们尽量这样做。有时，对于安全性要求较低的东西，
we'll use, you know, like the browsers remember passwords, but we try to be very careful not to use that so much. I don't, I guess just a little bit of paranoia. Well, and you know, your computer could break unless you're using the one where it remembers across, like it's tied to your user account. Yeah. Yeah, the Kee pass is really nice i have
我们会使用浏览器记住密码的功能，但我们尽量小心，不要过多使用它。我不知道，可能只是有点偏执。嗯，而且你知道，你的电脑可能会坏掉，除非你使用的是那种跨设备记住密码的功能，比如绑定到你的用户账户。是的。是的，KeePass 真的很好。我有
the uh the android app which um it can actually uh use the fingerprint scanner so when you launch the app you just fingerprint in and then you uh it also has this cool integration where um it puts a button it basically makes a key pass keyboard on android and so if you kind of uh if you if you click on where you need to put in a password, you change keyboard, it says KeePass keyboard, and then it can actually associate every app with a password. And so just based on the app you're on, you just fingerprint in and the password gets put in automatically. So yeah, KeePass is the way to go.
安卓应用，它可以利用指纹扫描仪，所以当你启动应用时，只需指纹识别，然后它还有一个很酷的集成，它在安卓上创建了一个 KeePass 键盘，所以如果你点击需要输入密码的地方，切换键盘，它会显示 KeePass 键盘，然后它可以将每个应用与一个密码关联起来。所以只需根据你使用的应用，指纹识别一下，密码就会自动填入。所以是的，KeePass 是首选。
It's totally open source. There's a bunch of different implementations. Implementations might not all be open source, obviously. But I think for Linux, I use KeePass XC, which used to be KeePass X, now it's XC, but I think it's on almost every Linux distribution. And for Android, I use, I think, Minikypass, something like that. Yep. There are a lot of good choices. You know, I actually would say choosing any that aren't super scammy.
它是完全开源的。有很多不同的实现。实现可能并不全是开源的，显然。但我认为对于 Linux，我使用 KeePassXC，它以前叫 KeePassX，现在是 XC，但我认为它几乎在每个 Linux 发行版上都有。对于安卓，我用的是 Minikypass 之类的。是的，有很多不错的选择。你知道，我其实会说，选择任何不是特别骗人的密码管理器，并让它生成安全的密码，都比尝试记住所有不安全的密码要好。是的。是的，绝对。但那不是我的背景。
So any of the sort of well-known password managers and having it generate sort of secure passwords is better than trying to memorize insecure passwords for everything. Yep. Yeah, absolutely. But that's not my background.
所以请咨询安全专家。是的，没错。所以一位希望保持匿名的听众问了几个问题。第一个是，关于工作保障，我们尽量快速回答，因为这可能会陷入深渊。作为个人，为了工作保障，
So consult a security expert. Yeah, right. So a listener who wished to remain anonymous asked a couple of questions. First one is, for job security, and we'll try to be a little rapid fire on this because this could be a rabbit hole. For job security as an individual,
是掌握多种语言的一点知识比较好，还是专注于单一语言比较好？你想先选 A 还是 B？是的，这是个好问题。我的意思是，老实说，我认为与其试图制定策略，不如更具反应性，对吧？我的意思是，我认为学习多种不同的语言对我来说至少是很迷人的。但每当你开始谈论什么比什么更好时，
is it best to have a little knowledge on a lot of languages or to specialize in just a single one? You want to take that first as an A or B selection? Yeah, it's a good question. I mean, I think honestly, instead of trying to strategize, you should really be more reactive, right? I mean, I think it's good to, for me at least, I think it's fascinating to learn about a bunch of different languages. But whenever you start talking about what's better than something else,
你立刻就开始谈论……你知道，其实这个人明确提到了工作保障。所以它总是归结为某种职业问题或某种优化问题，对吧？所以我想，我会把学习不同的语言看作是一种哲学练习之类的东西，这是一种好事。
you immediately start talking about like, you know, actually this person explicitly said job security. So it always comes down to some type of career thing or some type of optimization thing, right? So I think, you know, like I would think of like learning different languages as sort of like an exercise in like philosophy or something like that, where it's a good thing to do.
这就像一个不错的爱好。它很有启发性。而且我认为它会在某种程度上以深奥的方式帮助你。但如果你的目标是工作保障，那么它就更具反应性了。所以你必须观察，OK，我现在有什么工作？这是我想要的工作吗？假设我想保住现在的工作，他们想要什么，我怎样才能给他们更多他们想要的东西？如果我想要一份不同的工作，我该如何朝着那个方向努力？所以它变得非常依赖语境，很难回答。这是个公平的观点。我想我的回答会是一种回避，说两者都不是，而且与 Jason 说的反应性有点不同，而是做让你
It's like a nice hobby. It's instructive. And I think it will help you in, let's say, somewhat like esoteric ways. But if your goal is, let's say, job security, then it's a bit more reactive. So you have to kind of see, OK, you know, what job do I have now? Is it the job I want? If assuming I want to keep the job i'm in right now what do they want and how can i give them more of that right if i want a different job how do i get towards that right so it's really it becomes much more contextual so it's hard to answer right that's a fair point i guess my answer here would be somewhat of a dodge and saying neither and a little different than what jason is saying about reaction but doing what makes
快乐的事情，因为我认为快乐会让你成为更好的员工，这会让你做出更好的工作，这会让你公司更喜欢你，作为一般规则。是的，那是真的。如果那行不通，那么你可能想找一家新公司。我知道这话说起来很轻松，但我发现这通常是真的。而且，我要说的是，对我来说，我认为有些人称之为“油漆滴法”、“帐篷杆法”，有很多名字。但我的意思是，它归结为拥有一两种你非常擅长的语言，你可以坐下来，人们会来找你寻求帮助，你知道，从里到外都很精通。
you happy because i think being happy will make you a better employee which will make you do better work which will make the company like you more as a general rule yeah that's true and if that doesn't work then like you might want to find a new company i know it's really tough speak i guess but like i've found that generally to be true um and but what i will say is for me i think having having some people call this like the paint drip method, the tentpole method, there's a variety of names it gets. But I mean, it just boils down to having one or two languages that you are really good at, that you like can sit down and people will come to you for like help assistance, you know, sort of inside and out.
然后任何其他你公司使用的语言，或者你熟悉的语言，拥有最低限度的可行工作知识。所以对我来说，过去是 Java，现在是 C++，我用 C++ 做很多事情，我绝不认为自己是专家，但我绝对精通到足以胜任我需要完成的所有任务。我们偶尔使用 Python，我相对来说不太擅长 Python，但我尽量做到足够好，
And then any other language that your company uses, or you're familiar with you know sort of inside and out and then any other language that your company uses or you're familiar with having a sort of minimally viable amount of working knowledge so for me that works out that like in the past it's been java right now it's c++ i do a lot of stuff in c++ and i by no means consider myself an expert but i'm definitely proficient enough to capably get all of the tasks i need to get done done in it. And we occasionally use Python, and I'm relatively bad at Python, but I try to be good enough
如果别人在用 Python 做事，我能跟上他们在做什么。我可以审查他们的代码。我可以提供建议。我可以在紧急情况下调试它。所以我不能在 Python 上太差，然后说“不，我不是 Python 程序员。我是 C++ 程序员。”
that if someone else is doing something in Python, I can follow what they're doing. I can review their code. I can offer suggestions. I can debug it in a pinch. So I can't be bad enough at Python and just say, nope, I'm not a Python guy. I'm C++.
“如果不是 C++，就滚开。”那不是个好答案。有些人会认为这是个好答案，我不喜欢那个答案。是的，我喜欢这个观点：你公司使用的所有东西，你都应该有基本的熟悉度。是的，或者至少愿意学习它。如果……是的，那很公平。嗯，那么第二个后续问题是，当整个组织决定切换编程语言时会发生什么？是的，我的意思是，我见过这种情况，一个非常大的组织改变了他们最流行的语言，我的意思是，这些事情是逐渐发生的。你知道，这些事情必须是自上而下的。
If it's not C++, get out of here um that's not a good answer some people will consider it a good answer i don't like that answer yeah i like this everything that your company uses you should be passingly familiar with yeah or at least willing to learn it if you yeah that's fair um then then the second sort of follow-up thing is what kind of things happen when a whole organization decides to switch programming languages yeah i mean i saw this uh where a very large organization changed kind of their most popular language and uh i mean these things happen gradually um you know there's you know there's there's uh you know these kind of things kind of have to be top down.
我的意思是，想法可以是自下而上的，但决定必须是自上而下的。没错。所以，一旦决定做出，就没有太多发言权了。所以这真的是关于学习新语言，利用它作为一个重构许多东西的机会。但是，是的，我不一定反对它。这绝对是一个不能掉以轻心的决定。
I mean, the idea could be bottom up, but then the decision has to be top down. Right. And so, you know, once, once a decision has been made, then there's not really much say. Right. So it's really about learning the new language, using it as an opportunity to refactor a lot of things. But, yeah, I mean, I'm not necessarily opposed to it. It's really, it's definitely a decision you can't take lightly.
但我认为说“OK，因为这种语言我们背负了多少债务？”真的很重要。或者它甚至可能不是整个语言，而是框架之类的。你知道，什么时候是做出改变的好时机，等等等等。是的，所以这里还有一些我遗漏的背景，但我的意思是，我认为当这种情况发生时，会有……不仅仅是切换框架，
But I think it is really important to say, okay, how much debt do we have because of this language? And, or it might not even be a whole language, but framework or what have you. And you know, when's a good time to make that move, et cetera, et cetera. Yeah, so there's some more context to this I sort of left out, but I mean, I think when this happens, there will be, especially not just switching frameworks,
而是切换整个语言。会有一些人基本上会辞职，他们不喜欢，“我是 Python 程序员，我不在乎每个人都认为我们要转向 C++，我要辞职。我做 Python。”嗯，这种情况会发生。嗯，我认为这总是很艰难。这种情况会发生。我认为这总是很艰难。总会有一些人喜欢原来的方式。但这几乎适用于生活中的任何变化，特别是在工作中。每当管理层试图改变某些东西时，总有一群人会说“嗯，以前更好”。每当出现错误时，人们都会指出来说“我告诉过你。我告诉过你这是个坏主意。”但是的，我认为正如 Jason 所说，它有时确实必须在最高层做出决定，即战略投资决定了“我们要向新的方向发展，无论代价如何”。我认为自下而上非常困难。是的。是的，没错。所以 Chris 问，OS X、Windows 还是 Linux？如果是 Linux，什么发行版？你日常使用什么？什么语言？我可以先来。我什么都用一点。
but switching whole languages. There will be people who will basically quit who they don't like I'm a Python person and I don't care that everybody thinks we're moving to C plus plus I'm quitting. I do Python. Um, that's going to happen. Um, I think it's, it's always rough. That's going to happen. I think it's always rough. There's going to be people who always liked it the way it was. But that's true of almost any change in just, I guess, in life, but especially at work. Anytime management tries to change something, some group of people are going to say, well, it was better before. Anytime there's a mistake, people are going to point and say, I told you so. I told you this was a bad idea. But yeah, I think as Jason said, it really sometimes has to be made just at the top where a strategic investment is decided that, you know, we're going to move in a new direction, kind of no matter the cost. Very difficult to do bottom up, I think. Yep. Yeah, that's right. So Chris asks, OS X, Windows or Linux? If Linux, what distro? What do you use day to day? What languages? So I could go first. I use a bit of everything.
在工作中，我有一台 MacBook，但我还有一台运行 Fedora 的 ThinkPad。它运行 Fedora。在工作中的云端，我们运行 CentOS。这其实是我第一次使用 Fedora。在工作中的云端，我们运行 CentOS。这其实是我第一次使用 Fedora。在家里，我运行 Ubuntu。所以什么都有。我确实有一台 Windows 机器，或者说，一台可以启动进入 Windows 的机器。那只是为了玩电子游戏。但其实，Windows 已经变得很不错了。所以，你知道，如果我必须从零开始，
At work, I have a MacBook, but I also have a ThinkPad that's running Fedora. It's running Fedora. And in the cloud at work, we're running CentOS. It's actually my first time using Fedora. It's running Fedora. And in the cloud at work, we're running CentOS. It's actually my first time using Fedora. At home, I run Ubuntu. So there's a bit of everything going on. I do have a Windows machine or a machine, I should say, a machine that can boot into Windows. That's only for playing video games. But actually, Windows has gotten really nice. So, you know, if I had to start from scratch,
我认为 Windows 是一个有吸引力的选择。但出于历史原因，我基本上有一台 Windows 盒子用来玩游戏。在家里，我一切都是 Linux。对于工作，我有一台 MacBook 和 Fedora。是的，我想我的情况类似。嗯，我目前不怎么用 Linux，过去用过。嗯，我大部分时间不喜欢笔记本上的 Linux。无论如何，我认为现在好多了，但仍然不理想。是的，而且对于……我发现尽管有溢价，MacBook 还是太好了，以至于即使它们很贵，
I think Windows is an attractive alternative. But just for historical reasons, I basically have a Windows box for games. At home, I have everything Linux. And for work, I have a MacBook and Fed in fedora yeah i guess mine is similar uh i don't use so much linux currently i have in the past um i dislike linux on laptops for the most part uh whatever i think it's better now but it's still not ideal yeah and and uh same thing for i just i haven't i found despite the surcharge on, that the MacBooks are just so nice that even though they're expensive,
直到最近都没有很好的替代品。所以笔记本是 OS X，台式机是 Windows，在家里。是的，顺便说一句，我完全同意关于笔记本的看法。讽刺的是，我有一台 ThinkPad。名字里有“Pad”，但触控板太糟糕了，它是塑料的，而不是像 Mac 那样是金属或玻璃之类的。嗯，ThinkPad 上的触控板简直太可怕了。嗯，所以是的，我同意，我认为 MacBook 的硬件明显更好。但在家里，我基本上放弃了
that until recently there's not been great alternatives. And so laptop is OS X, desktop is Windows, sort of at home. Yeah, I totally agree about the laptop, by the way. Ironically, I have a ThinkPad. It has pad in the name, and the trackpad is so bad like it's it's plastic instead of i think the mac is either metal or glass or something like that and uh the trackpad on the on the thinkpad is just terrible um so so yeah i agree i think the hardware is just significantly better on the macbook but at home i've mostly given up the
笔记本电脑，我不认为我会再更换旧笔记本了。我不知道。大多数时候我们用平板电脑和手机，然后我们有一台 Windows 台式机，当我想要玩游戏或者我们需要做照片编辑之类的东西时使用。你平时怎么做，比如，假设你需要写一份文档，比如用 Microsoft Word，然后你需要打印它。你在平板电脑上怎么做？哦，我的意思是，我走到台式机前，使用 Google Docs，然后使用我的打印机。
laptop thing like i don't think I'll replace old laptops ever again. I don't know. Mostly we go on to tablets and phones and then we have a desktop that's Windows for when I want to play games or we need to do sort of photo editing or, you know, whatever kind of thing. What do you do for like, like, let's say you need to write a document in, let's say something like Microsoft Word, and then you need to print it. How do you do that on your tablet? Oh, I mean, I go on the desktop and use Google Docs and use my printer.
好的，明白了。你有办法从平板电脑上打印吗？是的，我们有办法。现在，它是通过电脑进行的，但那是因为我们有一台非常旧的打印机。我认为现代打印机通常有应用程序，你可以直接打印，比如你把它保存为 PDF，然后通过应用程序打印 PDF。
Okay, got it. Do you have a way to print from the tablet? Yeah, so we do have a way. Right now, it goes through via the computer, but that's because we have a really old printer. I think modern printers have normally apps on them where you can print directly from, like you sort of save it to a PDF and then you print the PDF via an app.
或者我认为 Apple 有 AirPrint 之类的东西，连接到一些打印机上。是的，这真的不是限制。但我的意思是，这就是为什么我们有台式机。如果我们需要做类似的事情，我们几乎总是直接用台式机。哦，其实还有第二组问题。你最喜欢的开发平台是什么，笔记本电脑还是台式机，智能手机？所以，是的，听起来我们俩在工作中都有笔记本电脑。然后显然大多数事情都是在云端完成的。
Or I think Apple has AirPrint or something that are hooked into some printers. Yeah, it's really not a limitation. But I mean, that is why we have the desktop. We almost always, if we need to do something like that, just get on the desktop. Oh, there's actually a second set of questions. What's your favorite development platform, laptop versus desktop, smartphone? So, yeah, I think it sounds like we both have laptops at work. And then there's obviously most of the things are done kind of in the cloud.
是的，这是开发平台的一个好问题。不，开发平台是为了——噢，抱歉。我想说在工作中我们使用 Atom。在家里我越来越多地使用 Visual Studio Code。你呢？所以对我来说，我在工作中确实有一台笔记本电脑，但除非必要，我不在上面开发。我总是使用台式机。编译速度更快，你知道，我今天做的所有事情都是这样。
Yeah, it's a good question for development platform. No, development platform for – oops, sorry. I was going to say at work we use Atom. At home I've been using more and more Visual Studio Code. What about you? So for me, I do have a laptop at work, but I don't develop on it unless I have to. I always use desktop. Faster compilation, you know, everything for the stuff I'm doing today.
是在云端还是物理台式机？不，本地，因为我现在做的事情。我做更多的应用开发。哦，我明白了。明白了。是的，是的。这取决于你在做什么。但目前，我非常喜欢大屏幕、
Like in the cloud or a physical desktop? No, locally, because of stuff I'm doing now. I'm doing more app development. Oh, I see. Got it. Yeah, yeah. That varies depending on what you're working on. But that currently, I very much like the large screen,
插上电源、快速的电脑。我不喜欢处理连接笔记本电脑的问题。不过很多人都这样做。而且我使用 IDE。我不会尝试使用 Eclipse，最近我尝试了一些 JetBrains 的东西。比如 CLion 和 IntelliJ。是的，我一直在研究这些，挺不错的。
plugged in, fast computer. I don't like dealing with hooking in the laptop. A lot of people do though. And I use IDEs. I don't, you know, try to use Eclipse or lately I've tried some of the JetBrains stuff. This is like Sea Lion and IntelliJ. Yeah, I've been digging those pretty good.
我只是一个 IDE 的忠实拥护者。我不知道，随便吧。我想我不是硬核玩家。嗯，是的，我其实切换过。我曾经是一个 Emacs 的忠实用户，现在我切换到了 IDE。我的意思是，让我切换的大事是远程开发。所以现在大多数 IDE 都有某种功能，你在实际执行代码的机器上运行服务器。所以基本上我的工作流程是，
I'm just a big IDE guy. I don't know, whatever. I guess I'm not hardcore. Well, yeah, I actually switch. I used to be a big Emacs person and now I've switched to IDE. I mean, the big thing that let me switch is the remote development. So most IDEs now have something where you run a server on the machine that's actually gonna execute this code. So basically the way my workflow is,
我到公司，把笔记本电脑插到屏幕上，然后我一直远程桌面。就像，我并没有在笔记本电脑上编译代码之类的。Atom 有一个插件，看起来像是在本地编辑文件，但这些文件实际上并不存在于你的机器上。它们都在云端的机器上。所以你拥有这个完整的 IDE。它甚至在做 IntelliSense 和所有这些事情，但它在你的 IDE 和
is I get to work, I plug my laptop into a screen, and I'm just remote desktop the whole time. It's like, I'm not actually compiling code on my laptop or anything. And there's a plugin for Atom where it looks like you're editing files locally, but none of those files actually exist on your machine. They're all on, you know, your machine in the cloud. And so you have this total IDE. It's even doing like IntelliSense and all these things, but it's doing a bunch of back and forth between your IDE and
在另一台机器上运行的某个服务之间进行大量的往返。所以现在我们切换到一些来自 Discord 的问题。第一个来自 BSD Tech，我要把它交给你，Jason。问题是，你如何处理 Python 中类型的变化？你如何处理 Python 中类型的变化？所以如果你想改变类型，你需要去重构你的代码，因为变量是一个新类型。C 语言……是的，这很简单，你只需要不断修复东西，直到编译器不再告诉你做错了。是的，这是一个非常非常好的问题。所以……嗯，我从不使用无类型的 Python，我认为那非常困难。我的意思是，
some service running on the other machine. So now we're switching over to some questions that came in from Discord. So this first one from BSD Tech, I'm going to give to you, Jason. The question is, how do you deal with types changing in Python? How do you deal with types changing in Python? So if you want to change the type and you need to go refactor your code because the thing is a new variable is a new type and c yeah this is straightforward you just keep fixing stuff until the compiler stops telling you you did it wrong yeah this is a really really good question so um uh i never do untyped python i think that's that's uh very difficult i mean
你知道，对于你正在做的脚本，对于简单的东西，没问题。但对于工作中的任何事情，我们对类型有相当严格的政策。所以对于不知道的人，如果你使用 Python 3，其实内置了类型系统。所以我想它叫类型提示（type hints），这意味着它们是可选的，所以你可以说 x 等于 3，什么都不会崩溃。但你也可以写 x 冒号 int 等于 3，然后稍后在代码中，如果你写 x 等于“狗”，它会抛出错误。所以 Python 实际的做法是，没有编译器，所以你必须运行一个单独的程序，我想它叫 mypy，它进行类型检查。所以 mypy 会分析你的代码，然后
you know for a script that you're doing, you know, for something simple, it's fine. But for anything at work, we have a pretty strict policy on types. So for people who don't know, if you're using Python 3, there's actually typing built in. So I think it's called type hints which means that you know they're optional so you could say you know x equals three and nothing's going to crash or anything like that but you can also do you know x colon int equals three and then later on in your code if you do you know x equals dog it'll throw an error and so what the way Python actually does it is there's no compiler so you have to run a separate program, I think it's called mypy, which does the type checking. And so mypy will just analyze your code and just
告诉你，“嘿，这个变量你说它是 int，但你把它设为‘狗’，它通不过。”对吧？把它想象成单元测试。所以，是的，我们在工作中做的一切都使用 Python 3 类型系统。所以，你知道，是的，如果有人有一个函数，函数接受一个 int，他们决定第一个参数应该是一个字符串，任何调用该函数的人都会……类型检查单元测试会开始失败。所以它基本上就像在写强类型代码。它确实给了你一点灵活性。所以可能有一些非常简单的东西，比如，
tell you, hey, you know, this variable you said it was an int but then you set it equal to dog and it won't pass, right? Think of it as like a unit test. And so, yeah, everything we do at work is using the Python 3 type system. And so, you know, yeah, if somebody has a function and the function takes an int and they decide that the first argument should be a string, anyone who calls that function will, you know, the type checking unit test will start failing. And so it's basically like writing strongly typed code at that point. It does give you a little bit more flexibility. So like there might be some very simple things like, you know,
X 等于某个函数的结果，然后返回 X 之类的。你知道，我们对在每个地方都加上类型不是特别严格。但所有的函数参数，我们都会标注类型，所有的函数返回值也都会标注类型。所以这解决了 99% 的问题。所以非常非常少见的情况下，我们会遇到一些问题，或者有人改变了类型，直到运行时才发现。我只在强类型语言中工作。是的，那部分容易得多。所以 McGee 问，我这学期上了一门叫“操作系统”的课，在这门课中，我们将用 C 语言创建一个基本的操作系统，显然还有一些汇编。在编写这类东西时，有哪些事情需要记住，
X equals the result of some function and then return X or something like that. You know, we're not super strict on putting a type every single place. But it but all of the function parameters, you know, we type and things like that, all the return values of functions are typed. And so that gets us around, you know, 99% of the issue. So very, very rarely, we'll have some issue or someone changed a type and it made it all the way into the runtime before we found out i only work in typed languages yeah that part's much easier so mcgee asked i'm taking a class this semester called operating systems in this class we'll be creating a basic os and c and apparently some assembly what are some things to keep in mind when writing something like this,
Patrick？好的。是的，我的意思是，如果是在课堂上，他们应该会给你很多结构。但我的意思是，我认为需要记住的事情是，
Patrick? Okay. Yeah. I mean, so if you're a class, they should give you a lot of structure around this, but I mean, I think the thing to keep in mind,
如果你是从零开始，你会写出一些代码，你可能不会在软件工程方法中这样做，因为你可能不得不为了优化而牺牲可读性，为了在不坚持关于干净代码应该是什么样子的严格理想的情况下完成某个系统。因为底层的操作系统东西可能不是最好的地方。但这是我的观点。人们可能会为此跟我争论。我绝不是 Linux 内核开发者，对事情应该如何做有强烈的看法。但我……对我来说，我并没有使用太多我在操作系统课上学到的特定技能，也没有做太多底层的东西。但了解计算机的工作原理绝对是我日常工作中用来帮助调试、理解堆栈溢出意味着什么、理解如果我得到内存不足异常时，
if you're kind of starting from scratch is that you will write, you might do stuff that you might not do in a software engineering approach because you might have to sacrifice readability, legibility for that optimization that you need in order to get some system done without holding to a stringent, you know, ideal about what clean code should look like. Because low level operating system stuff is probably not the best place for it. But that's my opinion. People will probably argue with me about that. And I'm not a Linux kernel developer by any means where you'll have a lot of strong opinions about how stuff should be done. But I for for me, I don't use much of the specific skills I learned in sort of operating systems class and doing low level stuff. But understanding how the computer works definitely gets used by me day to day to help with debugging, understanding what the stack overflow means, understanding if I get an out-of-memory exception,
什么会导致这种情况。了解所有这些东西在底层是如何工作的，是我从这类课程中得到的真正巨大的收获，即概念和理解什么是操作系统以及它为你做什么。是的，这很有道理。我修过系统软件，我想那是操作系统的先修课。我从来没修过操作系统，我在努力回忆它是否是必修课，
like what would likely lead to that. Just knowing how all those things work under the hood is the really big takeaway that I've had from those kind of classes is the concepts and understanding what an operating system is and what it does for you. Yeah, that makes sense. I took system software, which I think was the prereq for os i never actually i don't think i actually took os i'm trying to remember if it was mandatory or not
我不认为它是，但……是的，最大的收获是我学会了如何调试非常底层的东西，这是我以前从未做过的。比如“段错误（seg fault）”，那到底是什么意思？是的，那是个好观点。是的，是的，我想……嗯，我想如果我必须给出一个建议，那就是给自己留出充足的时间，因为错误非常深奥。如果你习惯于做一些非常高级的事情，比如 BASIC 或 Python 之类的，你习惯于看到“哦，我除以零了”，它会告诉你。而在 C 语言中，你知道，它不一定会立刻告诉你出错了，它只会导致一些类似不理想的
i don't think it was but uh yeah the big thing was uh i learned how to you know debug really low-level things which i'd never done before like it's like uh like seg fault like what does that even mean yeah that's a good point yeah yeah i think uh um yeah i guess the best advice i guess if i had to give a piece of advice is to give yourself lots of time because the errors are really esoteric it's if you're used to doing something like really high level like basic or python or something like that you're used to seeing like like oh i divided by zero and it'll actually tell you that you know and see you know it won't necessarily tell you you have an error right away it'll just cause some like undesirable
行为。所以……是的，那不是你应该在最后一刻才写的东西。很有道理。嗯，Veller 问，我们以后会重温节目中的话题吗？哦，这是个好问题。我想不可避免吧，对吧？我想是的。我的意思是，肯定有些事情已经改变了。我们会重温节目中的话题吗？哦，这是个好问题。我想不可避免吧，对吧？我想是的。我的意思是，肯定有些事情已经改变了。你知道，有些人要求我们涵盖 TensorFlow、PyTorch 之类的东西。你知道，我们确实涵盖了……我想我们涵盖了通用的 BLAS 类型库，
behavior and so uh yeah that's not something you should be writing like the last minute fair enough uh veller asks will we ever revisit topics on the show oh that's a good question i guess inevitably right i think so i mean there's definitely things that have changed Will we ever revisit topics on the show? Oh, that's a good question. I guess inevitably, right? I think so. I mean, there's definitely things that have changed pretty drastically. You know, some people were asking us to cover, you know, TensorFlow, PyTorch, these things. You know, and we did cover, you know, I think we covered in general Blas type libraries,
但它们改变了太多，对吧？所以是的，我想它涵盖了通用的 BLAS 类型库，但它们改变了太多，对吧？所以是的，我想这会发生，但我认为我们不会在任何时候说“清空一切，从 C++ 开始”。那可能不会发生。但是的，我想我们会……特别是如果这些东西非常动态，我们会重温它们。
but they've changed so much, right? So yeah, I think it covered in general Blas-type libraries, but they've changed so much, right? So yeah, I think it will happen, but I don't think we're going to at any point say, wipe the slate clean and start with C++. That probably won't happen. But yeah, I think we'll kind of, especially if these things are very dynamic, we'll revisit them.
是的，我的意思是，我认为总的来说，我们节目的形式多年来已经发生了相当大的变化。所以我认为重温其中一些事情是有意义的，特别是在更细微的点上。就像 Jason 刚才谈到的用类型提示编写 Python。我认为像那样的事情，我们可以讨论一些特定的东西，这些东西在我们第一次谈论 Python 时并不存在。但我认为涵盖整个 Python，是的，我不知道，也许吧。是的，我也不知道，这是一个非常好的问题。我的意思是，它是一个……一个相当抽象的
Yeah, I mean, I think in general, the format of our show has changed a decent amount over the years. And so i think revisiting some of those things will make sense specifically in more fine points right like like jason was just talking about writing using writing python using types uh type hints and i think something like that you know we could get into a discussion about some specific thing that sort of wasn't around when you know we first talked about python but i think covering python as a whole yeah i don't know maybe yeah i don't know either it's a really good question i mean it's a um it's a pretty abstract
是的，我的意思是，我认为总的来说，我们节目的形式多年来已经发生了相当大的变化。所以我认为重新审视其中一些内容是有意义的，特别是在更细微的方面，就像杰森刚才谈到的使用类型提示编写 Python，我认为像这样的事情，你知道，我们可以讨论一些在我们要么第一次谈论 Python 时还没有出现的事情，但我认为全面涵盖 Python，是的，我不知道，也许吧，我也不知道，这是一个非常好的问题，我的意思是，这是一个相当抽象的问题。
answer i guess so it really just depends on the circumstance i guess in the future we will know yeah so appetite appetite appetite nine i guess appetite nine asks, what do you listen to while you work? That's a good question. I actually used this thing called Nativeifier. It's a Node.js binary. So it's basically a program. And it will take any website and kind of wrap it up into an app and so it kind of looks like an app feels like an app you can alt tab etc etc but it's
答案我想是这样，这真的取决于具体情况。我想未来我们会知道的。是的，那么 Appetite Nine，我想是 Appetite Nine 问，你工作时听什么？这是个好问题。我实际上用了一个叫 Nativeifier 的东西。它是一个 Node.js 二进制文件。所以它基本上是一个程序。它可以获取任何网站并将其包装成一个应用程序，所以它看起来像一个应用程序，感觉也像一个应用程序，你可以使用 Alt+Tab 等等，但它
really a website and so i did that with the twitch.tv slash monster cat it's just this it's just this uh twitch channel that plays basically techno music 24 7 and uh sometimes i'll i'll fire that up um i i have a tendency to uh just not really listen to too much of anything when i'm at work um sometimes i'll listen to um people who talk about philosophy so uh you know because i feel like it's the kind of thing where it's it's pretty generic um it's kind of nice to just listen to while you're doing something. So I'll listen to like Stefan Molyneux and like other sort of just philosophers that just did like they do a whole thing on on Aristotle. So it's like two hours on Aristotle. And I might, you know, consciously absorb maybe 15 minutes of it.
实际上是一个网站。所以我对 twitch.tv/monstercat 做了同样的事情，它只是一个 24 小时全天候播放科技音乐的 Twitch 频道。有时我会启动它。我倾向于在工作时不太听什么东西。有时我会听一些谈论哲学的人的节目，因为我觉得这是一种很通用的东西，在做事情时听听感觉不错。所以我听像 Stefan Molyneux 这样的人，以及其他一些哲学家，他们会做关于亚里士多德的专题。比如两个小时都在讲亚里士多德。我可能只会下意识地吸收其中的 15 分钟。
But it's really just kind of something to have going on. Same with the techno music. Like it's really just something to kind of have a rhythm going on. Um, but, uh, yeah, that's, that's me. What about you, Patrick? Do you listen to music or, um, yeah, I, that's a mix of stuff. Sometimes I'll put on some YouTube show in the background or like, I guess you were saying like a live stream or something. Uh, sometimes I just have my headphones on and nothing playing to dampen the, I mean, I don't have like noise canceling headphones but you know just in general they close off the sound a little and it's a signal to people that like i'm thinking so which we'll have to talk about i guess in more depth at some other time um but yeah same thing i
但这真的只是为了有个背景音。科技音乐也是一样。这真的只是为了保持一种节奏感。嗯，但这就是我。你呢，Patrick？你听音乐吗？或者，是的，那是一堆东西的混合。有时我会放一些 YouTube 节目作为背景，或者像你说的直播之类的。有时我只是戴着耳机，什么也不放，为了减弱噪音。我的意思是，我没有降噪耳机，但你知道，总的来说，它们能稍微隔绝一点声音，这向人们发出一个信号，表明我在思考。我们以后可能需要更深入地讨论这个问题，但是的，同样的事情，我
guess i listen to various electronic music i don't know why it's like when i'm not at work i don't really listen to that music uh i don't listen to music that much but at work i do i don't i guess it's a stereotype i don't know recently i've been like for some reason i found some good glitch music which is i'm terrible with music but it's like i guess somewhere between techno and dubstep okay yeah anyways i just found like this playlist i checked it out one time and it had some cool music i liked in there um so just various playlists on things like spotify or google play music or pandora i'll just sort of scroll through whatever hot playlist they have and and sort of play mostly something electronic in nature yeah one time i uh
猜我听各种电子音乐。我不知道为什么，就像我不工作的时候，我其实不太听那种音乐。我不怎么听音乐，但在工作时我会听。我猜这是一种刻板印象，我不知道。最近我不知为何发现了一些不错的故障音乐（glitch music），我对音乐一窍不通，但它大概介于科技音乐和回响贝斯（dubstep）之间。好吧，总之，我只是找到了这个播放列表，我试听了一次，里面有一些我喜欢的很酷的音乐。所以，在 Spotify、Google Play Music 或 Pandora 之类的平台上，我会浏览他们拥有的任何热门播放列表，并播放大部分电子风格的音乐。是的，有一次我
was really into trap music which is like techno plus rap oh actually the name now makes sense i never really thought about it i didn't until you just said that yeah that i didn't either and i've been listening but but anyway so so uh so i've been listening i was listening to this techno rap uh uh is like four hours of techno rap. I was like, okay. And so then I ended up going to a meeting and then going straight home afterwards. This was a Friday night. I get to the office Monday morning and YouTube had been running for the entire weekend.
真的很迷陷阱音乐（trap music），也就是科技音乐加说唱。哦，现在名字有意义了，我之前从没想过。直到你刚才说出来我才想到。是的，我也没想过，但我一直在听。但不管怎样，我当时在听这种科技说唱，大概有四个小时的科技说唱。我想，好吧。然后我开完会直接回家了。那是周五晚上。周一早上我到办公室，发现 YouTube 整个周末都在运行。
And because I have YouTube Red, it didn't do commercials. It didn't stop. It literally ran the whole weekend. And I don't know how it went from techno rap to just a live stream of a zoo. But at some point, the related video went to a live stream of a zoo. And you know, that thing doesn't end. And so I watched a live stream of a zoo, not actually watched but for for about a day and a half and then youtube will just incessantly show you yes for 90 days exactly 90 days i got
因为我有 YouTube Red，所以没有广告。它没有停止。它真的运行了整个周末。我不知道它是怎么从科技说唱变成动物园直播的。但在某个时候，相关视频跳转到了动物园的直播。你知道，那个东西是不会结束的。所以我看了一场动物园的直播，不是真的在看，但大概看了一天半。然后 YouTube 就会不断地向你展示，是的，整整 90 天，我得到了
recommendations to watch zoo animals like my entire youtube page was just dominated by that and literally on the 91st day because i didn't click on any of them on the 91st day it switched back can you like not like say i don't like this video did you ever i tried yeah i did it like two or three times and they're like oh well we'll show you this other koala bear yeah you don't like koala bears how about polar bears oh oh man life pro tip Don't leave YouTube running. Yeah, it's true. Peter says, what are the best work from home positions?
观看动物的推荐。我的整个 YouTube 页面都被那个占据了。直到第 91 天，因为我没有点击其中任何一个，第 91 天它才换回来。你不能说我不喜欢这个视频吗？你试过吗？我试过，是的，我试了两三次，他们说，哦，好吧，我们给你看这个考拉。是的，你不喜欢考拉？那北极熊怎么样？哦，天哪。生活小贴士：不要让 YouTube 一直运行。是的，这是真的。Peter 问，最好的居家办公职位是什么？
Sometimes it's hard to work remote, but are there any positions that are a good fit? Does it depend more on the company, culture, coworkers? I'll take a stab at this. Sure. The answer is it depends. All right, done. We'll stop. Yeah, I don't know.
有时远程工作很难，但有什么职位比较合适吗？这更多取决于公司、文化、同事吗？我来试着回答一下。当然。答案是视情况而定。好了，结束了。我们停下吧。是的，我不知道。
I've never actually, have you ever, I mean, we've never worked remote, but have you ever done, let's say, a remote project? No. Where everyone else was somewhere else? So for the most part, I haven't. And I think this largely depends on where you work and the company. So we both work in California in the Bay Area,
我从来没有，你有没有，我的意思是，我们从来没有远程工作过，但你有没有做过，比如说，一个远程项目？没有。就是每个人都在别的地方？所以大部分情况下，我没有。而且我认为这很大程度上取决于你在哪里工作以及公司。所以我们都在加州的湾区工作，
so near sort of San francisco and it's not super popular here um it's beginning to get more notice but in actuality some places are kind of moving against it and trying to bring more people into less locations uh forget sort of even like work from home or work remote um for support roles, I see a lot of people covering different time zones. And that makes a lot of sense to me. But in other roles, I don't typically see it. And there are a lot of problems with it. I would love to see it work well. But I've never seen something where in the kind of work I do, which is highly collaborative, sort of a lot of speculative work, a lot of day-to-day
靠近旧金山，这里不太流行。它开始受到更多关注，但实际上有些地方正在反其道而行之，试图将更多人集中到更少的地方。别说居家办公或远程工作了，对于支持类角色，我看到很多人覆盖不同的时区。这对我来说很有意义。但在其他角色中，我通常看不到这种情况。而且它有很多问题。我很想看到它运作良好。但我从未见过在我所从事的工作中，那种高度协作、 speculative（推测性）工作、很多日常
change. It's not so much like here we have a product and we're just trying to sort of burn down bugs that have been filed against the product. Remote work is kind of hard to do. But I guess in that way, I could see that some work would be more well-suited to it, right? Yeah, I know somebody who was, they were doing a startup and each person was basically in a different part of the globe. And it ended up actually working out pretty well because the startup was very focused.
变化的工作中，远程工作能很好地进行。它不像我们有一个产品，我们只是试图解决针对该产品提交的错误。远程工作很难做到。但我猜从这个角度来看，我可以看到有些工作会更适合它，对吧？是的，我认识一个人，他们正在创业，每个人基本上都在地球的不同地方。结果实际上效果还不错，因为这家初创公司非常专注。
So basically they were trying to do speech to text. And so what they would do is they would do a pitch. So all of them would have to fly to this customer pitch them on their product if the customer bought it the customer would give them just a ton of voice recordings then they would pay contractors to you know manually transcribe them and then they would write know, computer programs to try to match that. And so there was, let's say, you know, a person in North Carolina who was doing, you know, just trying to get the utterances right. And he had sort of a ground truth of what the right utterances were. So just he was just getting the accuracy higher and higher. But there's really, there wasn't a lot of collaboration. I mean, if one part of the system got much better or changed,
所以基本上他们试图做语音转文字。所以他们会做一次推介。他们所有人都必须飞到客户那里，向他们推销他们的产品。如果客户买了，客户会给他们大量的录音，然后他们会付钱给承包商，你知道，手动转录它们，然后他们会编写计算机程序来尝试匹配这些内容。所以，假设有一个人在北卡罗来纳州，他只是在努力把话语弄对。他有一种关于正确话语的“地面实况”（ground truth）。所以他只是在不断提高准确性。但真的没有太多的协作。我的意思是，如果系统的一部分变得更好或发生了变化，
you know, I guess they'd have to tell everyone downstream. But in the grand scheme of things, it's not, it's very low on the scale of collaboration. And that seemed to work pretty well for everybody. But yeah, I think to what Patrick was saying, you know, most jobs aren't like that, like in most jobs, you need to collaborate. And so being remote is pretty difficult. But that being said, people talk about it more now than they used to. And I think there's increasing desire for people to begin to have this as an option.
你知道，我想他们必须告诉下游的每个人。但在大局上，它在协作规模上是非常低的。这似乎对每个人都运作得很好。但是的，我认为正如 Patrick 所说，你知道，大多数工作不是那样的，在大多数工作中，你需要协作。所以远程工作是相当困难的。但话虽如此，人们现在谈论它的次数比以前多了。而且我认为人们越来越希望开始拥有这个选项。
But I also think like just being brutally honest, some people do better remote work than other people. Like it's a different skill being able to sit. I guess it depends on what you mean by remote. If it's like work from your house by yourself. Some people are very well suited to that. Others are not very well suited to that. They get distracted. They don't work as hard. And it just depends. It's a person by person thing. And then your company's reception to it is different. But I'm also I know I tended to work at pretty large companies. And I find that being in the office, having FaceTime with the bosses, like meeting people, that kind of stuff helps me do well in my career more than straight up just like being an amazing programmer is also important to do. But, you know, having that FaceTime and having people know who you are and keeping communications open and, you know, making sure I understand what's needed and then doing those things that are needed is important. And I feel for me, some of that would have been lost if I had not been in the central office where most of those people were. Yep. makes sense i agree 100 yeah if you can
但我同时也认为，坦率地说，有些人比其他人更适合远程工作。这是一种不同的技能，能够坐下来。我猜这取决于你所说的远程是什么意思。如果是指独自在家工作。有些人非常适合那样。其他人则不太适合。他们会分心。他们工作不够努力。这完全因人而异。而且你公司对它的接受程度也不同。但我知道我倾向于在相当大的公司工作。我发现身处办公室，与老板面对面交流，结识人们，这类事情比单纯成为一名出色的程序员更能帮助我在职业生涯中取得成功。当然，成为一名出色的程序员也很重要。但是，你知道，拥有那种面对面的交流，让人们知道你是谁，保持沟通畅通，并确保我理解需要什么，然后做那些需要做的事情是很重要的。我觉得对我来说，如果我没有在大多数人所在的中央办公室，其中一些东西就会丢失。是的，有道理，我 100% 同意。是的，如果你能
avoid remote work i mean i guess not not if you can avoid it but like definitely take into consideration the fact that the facetime is really really really important so but i i mean but i could see how a combination of video chatting and regular visits and like i i could see how you could make it work yeah I just don't have any great firsthand experience with it. So I can't say too much. Yep. Same here. Riley C52 asks, what are some of the best places to discover new open source projects and contribute to them? Yeah, we get this question a lot, right? I think it's a really good question. This one's actually phrased a little bit in a very interesting way because it's about sort of discovery. You know, in general,
避免远程工作，我的意思是，我猜不是如果你能避免它，而是绝对要考虑到面对面交流非常非常非常重要。所以，但我可以看到视频聊天和定期访问的结合，我可以想象你是如何让它工作的。是的，我只是没有任何直接的经验。所以我不能说太多。是的，我也是。Riley C52 问，发现新的开源项目并为之做出贡献的最佳地点有哪些？是的，我们经常收到这个问题，对吧？我认为这是一个非常好的问题。这个问题实际上措辞非常有趣，因为它涉及发现。你知道，总的来说，
my general philosophy is that you should start with sort of a problem that you want to solve and then try to find the open source solution and then improve it rather than, you know, join something that's doing something that, you know, it's like join some astrophysics open source library, even though you don't care about astrophysics. That's probably not, you know, like a good bet there, even if the code's really good and the people are good. Like you want to start with a problem that you want to solve. You know, you can, one thing I typically do, and I'm looking for open source projects is I just go into Google and I type some keywords and then use the site
我的总体哲学是，你应该从你想解决的问题开始，然后尝试找到开源解决方案，然后改进它，而不是，你知道，加入一些正在做一些，你知道，比如加入某个天体物理学开源库，即使你不关心天体物理学。那可能不是，你知道，一个好的选择，即使代码真的很好，人也很好。你想从你想解决的问题开始。你知道，你可以，我通常做的一件事，当我寻找开源项目时，我只是进入谷歌，输入一些关键词，然后使用 site
colon github.com so that I only see results from GitHub. That's, that's one way to do it. But yeah, in general, it's like really just start with a problem and then, you know, start your search there and you'll, you'll find something you're more passionate about. So Grant asks two questions. I'll take the second one and then I'll leave the first one to you to go second. And so Grant's first question is about immutable versus mutable objects. And this is a discussion I've heard go around a lot recently with the whatever current interest in functional programming is often the the case yeah and I think that there are good points to making as much of
冒号 github.com，这样我就只能看到来自 GitHub 的结果。这是，这是一种方法。但总的来说，就像真的从一个问题开始，然后，你知道，从那里开始你的搜索，你会，你会找到一些你更感兴趣的东西。所以 Grant 问了两个问题。我来回答第二个，然后我把第一个留给你来回答。所以 Grant 的第一个问题是关于不可变对象与可变对象。这是一个我最近经常听到的讨论，无论当前对函数式编程的兴趣如何，通常都是这种情况。是的，我认为在使尽可能多的
your system immutable as is reasonable and I think it's one of those gut feeling things as to what is reasonable I think taking and saying I don't care where some bit of something is in the system i'm gonna allow all pieces of the system to mutate it yeah that that obviously is bad you end up with things like you hear this global variables global state state balls these things where it's just like oh hey there's this bit of where we keep all of the interesting things in the system and all the pieces of code can call into it and write to it and it just sort of gets touched by all over the place. That ends up really hard to debug, very confusing, not great.
系统部分保持不可变方面是有道理的，我认为什么是合理的，这是一种直觉。我认为采取并说我不关心系统中的某一点东西在哪里，我要允许系统的所有部分去改变它，是的，这显然是不好的。你最终会得到像你听到的全局变量、全局状态、状态球（state balls）这样的东西，所有这些东西，就像哦，嘿，这里有我们保存系统中所有有趣东西的地方，所有的代码片段都可以调用它并写入它，它就到处被触碰。这最终变得非常难以调试，非常令人困惑，不太好。
On the other hand, saying nothing in the system can really be mutable, everything's immutable, which is what happens in some extent in functional programming, although they have concepts for how to deal with mutability, that can also run into some difficult situations where things become a little less straightforward. So in general, what I would try to say is, you know, limit mutability to as small a set of components as you can and when there's disparate components that need to you know potentially mutate shared things is like define a good interface around them and not so much say that the whole system should be immutable or now just whatever who cares does
另一方面，说系统中没有任何东西可以是可变的，一切都是不可变的，这在某种程度上发生在函数式编程中，尽管他们有关于如何处理可变性的概念，但这也会遇到一些困难的情况，事情变得不那么直接。所以总的来说，我想说的是，将可变性限制在尽可能小的一组组件中，当有不同的组件需要，你知道，潜在地改变共享事物时，就像在它们周围定义一个好的接口，而不是说整个系统应该是不可变的，或者现在不管谁在乎，让
everything be mutability is by default say like is it reasonable to have this component be immutable? And if so, make it that. And then use the mutability where it makes sense. Yeah, I find like these questions often get answered when you go to write tests. So if you go to write some kind of unit test that only tests one piece of the functionality, then, and you have like, let's say, as Patrick said, some huge global object, right? Then one of two things will have to happen. You're going to have to put that huge global object
一切默认都是可变的，说，让这个组件保持不可变合理吗？如果是这样，就那样做。然后在使用有意义的地方使用可变性。是的，我发现当你去编写测试时，这些问题通常会得到回答。所以如果你去编写某种只测试功能的一小部分的单元测试，那么，如果你有，就像 Patrick 说的，某个巨大的全局对象，对吧？那么两件事之一必须发生。你必须把那个巨大的全局对象
into the right state for that unit test to pass, which is usually really hard. Or you're going to have to kind of break that down. And so usually when you come to write unit tests and get good code coverage and things like that, that's where a lot of these problems become revealed, right? That's a great point. Yeah, I mean, I've started like, I think it's like proto3 is immutable.
放入正确的状态以使该单元测试通过，这通常非常困难。或者你必须把它分解。所以通常当你去编写单元测试并获得良好的代码覆盖率等时，这些问题中的许多就会显露出来，对吧？这是一个很好的观点。是的，我的意思是，我已经开始，我想是 proto3 是不可变的。
So in proto2, you could just, if you had a protobuf object called foo and it had an int x, you could just say foo.x equals 2 int x you could just say foo.x equals two and the next line could be foo.x equals four uh with proto3 at least in python um they made it immutable and so uh you actually have to create a new proto object where x is three and then create another second object where x is two and it copies does a deep copy right um and so you know my my style has changed just because of that but yeah i think again like the the testing really will give you the answer so you know if you if you go to write a test for something and your test is like you know call main
所以在 proto2 中，你可以，如果你有一个名为 foo 的 protobuf 对象，它有一个 int x，你可以直接说 foo.x 等于 2，下一行可以是 foo.x 等于 4。在 proto3 中，至少在 Python 中，他们把它变成了不可变的，所以你实际上必须创建一个新的 proto 对象，其中 x 是 3，然后创建第二个对象，其中 x 是 2，它会进行深拷贝，对吧？所以你知道，我的风格已经改变了，仅仅因为那个原因。但是的，我认为再次强调，测试真的会给你答案。所以你知道，如果你去为某事编写测试，而你的测试是，你知道，调用 main
did it return zero then you say okay well yeah you know i tested you know the entire program in one test now i need to break that down. It's like, oh, I can't test this function because it requires just so much state and so much overhead that I can't even start this function unless I'm running my program. And then you'll eventually get to fixing all those issues and mutability will happen along the way. So Grant also asks, new AI libraries like TensorFlow, Keras, PyTorch, MXNet. Yeah, I mean, there's definitely, you know, I could see people getting sort of analysis paralysis here. In general, they're all really good. I mean, I think it's, you know think MXNet has some advantages. I think that's from Amazon or Microsoft.
它返回零了吗？然后你说好吧，是的，你知道，我在一个测试中测试了整个程序，现在我需要把它分解。就像，哦，我不能测试这个函数，因为它需要太多的状态和太多的开销，以至于除非我运行我的程序，否则我甚至无法启动这个函数。然后你最终会修复所有这些问题，可变性会随之而来。所以 Grant 还问，新的 AI 库，如 TensorFlow、Keras、PyTorch、MXNet。是的，我的意思是，肯定有，你知道，我可以看到人们在这里产生某种分析瘫痪。总的来说，它们都非常好。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，我认为 MXNet 有一些优势。我想那是来自亚马逊或微软的。
But there's one from Amazon that runs really well on AWS. There's a Microsoft one that runs, you know, it's very compatible with Azure, so on and so forth. You know, Keras is trying to be a layer on top of all of those. I don't really see Keras going very far because the owner, the kind of core maintainer of Kairos, I think he went to Google
但有一个来自亚马逊的，在 AWS 上运行得非常好。有一个微软的，运行得，你知道，它与 Azure 非常兼容，等等。你知道，Keras 试图成为所有这些之上的一个层。我真的没看到 Keras 能走多远，因为所有者，Keras 的核心维护者，我想他去了谷歌
and works on TensorFlow now. Yeah. So, you know, again, this is one of these things that like, it's sort of like if you go to a music store and, you know, they have a whole bunch of different kinds of guitars. I'm not a music person at all, right?
现在在 TensorFlow 工作。所以，你知道，再次强调，这是这些事情之一，就像如果你去一家音乐商店，你知道，他们有很多不同种类的吉他。我根本不是一个音乐人，对吧？
But I know that they have tons of different kinds of guitars. You know, they have a whole bunch of different kinds of guitars. I'm not a music person at all, right? But I know that they have tons of different kinds of guitars. You know, they have some guitars are $20,000 and stuff like that, right? But, you know, if you just pick up a guitar and start playing, you're going to get a lot further along than someone who spends a year trying to find the best guitar, right? And so all these libraries are very solid. They're all backed by really large corporations they all have sort of pros and cons but they're the pros and cons are pretty esoteric right so um uh so yeah i guess my advice would be you know just grab one and just start running with it
但我知道他们有各种各样的吉他。你知道，他们有各种各样的吉他。我根本不是一个音乐人，对吧？但我知道他们有各种各样的吉他。你知道，有些吉他价值 2 万美元之类的，对吧？但是，如果你只是拿起一把吉他开始弹奏，你会比那些花一年时间试图找到最好吉他的人走得更远，对吧？所以所有这些库都非常扎实。它们都有非常大的公司支持，它们都有各自的优缺点，但优缺点相当深奥。所以，嗯，所以是的，我想我的建议是，你知道，随便抓一个就开始运行它。
um you know i personally uh like pytorch um but i haven't used MXNet, so I can't say anything about that. I do think that Theano and, to a lesser degree, TensorFlow 1.0 are getting pretty obsolete, so people have just learned lessons from them. TensorFlow 2.0, I think, is coming out soon. That should be really nice. The latest one is always going to learn lessons from the ones before it, right? But yeah, I wouldn't spend too much time worrying about which one. Just pick one and start building some crazy robot.
嗯，你知道，我个人喜欢 PyTorch，但我没有用过 MXNet，所以我不能说任何关于它的事情。我确实认为 Theano 和，在较小程度上，TensorFlow 1.0 正在变得相当过时，所以人们已经从它们身上吸取了教训。TensorFlow 2.0，我想很快就会出来。那应该会非常好。最新的一个总是会从它之前的那些身上吸取教训，对吧？但是的，我不会花太多时间担心选哪一个。随便选一个，开始建造一些疯狂的机器人吧。
Well, that was a pretty good collection of mailbag questions. Yeah, that covered a really wide spectrum, right? So, well, it's been a good episode. Yeah, thank you folks for listening to the live show on discord um one of these days we're going to try and get it set up where people can actually literally ask questions and they would be on the air i'm going to have to look into that i know there are other i follow actually other youtube um like podcasters and youtubers who do that so i know it's possible but we haven't got it set up yet we're not sophisticated enough yeah that's right um so thanks again for supporting us on
好吧，那是一组相当不错的邮件袋问题。是的，涵盖了非常广泛的范围，对吧？所以，嗯，这是一个很好的剧集。是的，感谢大家收听 Discord 上的直播节目。有一天我们要尝试设置一下，让人们可以真正地提问，并且他们会在广播中。我得研究一下。我知道有其他的，我实际上关注其他的 YouTube，比如播客和 YouTuber 这样做，所以我知道这是可能的，但我们还没有设置好。我们还不够成熟。是的，没错。嗯，所以再次感谢你们在
patreon um have fun with the with the coasters we had a lot of fun kind of shipping them out it was definitely interesting experience and uh yeah send us a tweet if you haven't already uh post a tweet at programming throwdown you know at mention us and uh send us a tweet if you haven't already. Post a tweet at Programming Throwdown, at mention us, and send us a picture of your souvenir. We'll catch you guys next month. Stop. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot.
Patreon 上支持我们。玩得开心，用那些杯垫。我们运送它们的过程很有趣，这绝对是一次有趣的经历。而且，是的，如果你还没有这样做，给我们发一条推文。发布一条推文 @ProgrammingThrowdown，你知道，@ 我们，如果你还没有这样做，给我们发一条推文。发布一条推文 @ProgrammingThrowdown，@ 我们，并发送一张你的纪念品照片。我们下个月见。停。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。
Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown 根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。